WE'D LIKE TO STAY THIS BILL
COMMITTEE ON OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY. WELL MEMBERS TAKE
THEIR SEATS SO WE CAN BEGIN- WE
CAN BE GAINED IS VERY IN-
SPECIAL COMMITTEE HEARING. ABA
FOR WE BEGIN- WE OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF COBIT- I'LL NEED TO
GO THROUGH OUR- OUR OUR LIST
OF- THINGS THAT WE DOING NOW
DURING COPAYS. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THIS
HEARING OF THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CONSIDER
THE GOVERNOR'S NOMINATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA. TO
BE THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL. I
WILL. GO AHEAD. I WOULD LIKE TO
MENTION A COUPLE OF TECHNICAL
IMPACT TWO ISSUES BEFORE WE GET
STARTED DUE TO THE ON DUTY TO
CONTINUE PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
TO WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASRI WARNING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ANY AND ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
TESTIFIED IN THE HEARING ROOM.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE
WILL PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU WE
HAVE A TWO DIFFERENT WE HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS HAS TESTIMONY TODAY
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OR
BY TELEPHONE THE WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA AT THE CALL IN
INFORMATION FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE- LATER IN THE HEARING
AGENDA. PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER
IS. 877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT
PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC ACCESS
NUMBER THAT YOU'LL BE REQUIRED
TO GIVE A ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
AGAIN THAT'S TWO. R. FOR TWO.
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. FOR THE IN
A ROOM TODAY. IN THE ASSEMBLY.
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
LIMON NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET SPACING. THERE THERE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DESCENDING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITOL BUT
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. I WOULD
LIKE. I WOULD I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCHED A
MICROPHONE. AT THE BEGINNING OF
PUBLIC COMMENT ASK OUR WILL BE
ASKING THEM TO MONITOR HOW MANY
COLORS ARE ON THE LINE. AND
THEN WE WILL BE WEAK WE CAN
DETERMINE THE TIME LIMITS IF
NECESSARY. SO THOSE ARE THE
AARON ROOM SO. I WILL LET. BOB
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
AGENDA RIGHT NOW IT'S YOU WHO
WHO IS HERE AS HOPEFULLY HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW- I SAW DO IT
JONES SAWYER HI I CAN DO IT FOR
OF IF LIVE I REACHED A VOICE
COMING FROM THE GAS YES PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JONES SAWYER HERE. MARK
STONE. OUR QUE HAN. SAL
CUNNINGHAM MEGAN THE- BRANNIGAN.
LACKEY HERE WICKS. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU SO FIRST WILL
HAVE WEALTHY OPENING COM FROM
TO COME CHAIRED THE HAVE A
OPENINGS BY THE HONORABLE RUN
BONTA AND THEN THEN WILL
RESPECT ON A OF THE NEXT
GENERAL- PUBLIC TO SO RIGHTS IN
THE AND- JUSTICE CAN. AND
SEXUAL SO THEY WILL HAVE
COMMENT AND THEN FIND WE WILL
HAVE THE COMMITTEE AND DELIVER
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THEN WILL CLOSE RIGHT TO
COMMITTEE CO CHAIR SO MISTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU MAY JONES SAWYER THIS IS A
RARE FOR THE SAN TO THE
PROVIDING OF AND- ON. A
GUBERNATORIAL PERHAPS IN THE
CIRCLE. WHERE THERE IS AN
APPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR OF
A CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER. THIS
IS A ROLE THAT NOW IS OUR THIRD
TIME FOR SOME OF US IN THE LAST
ASKED TO TAKE UNDERTAKE THIS.
WITH THE- RECENT FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH THE
CURRENT SECRETARY OF STATE AND
NOW WITH THIS. ATTORNEY GENERAL
APPOINTMENTS. SO OUR ROLE HERE
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CREATING AN APPROPRIATE
RECORDS. AND ESTABLISHING. IN
THIS COMMITTEE THE PATH
FORWARD. FOR THE ASSEMBLY THEN
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE OUR
RECOMMENDATION FOR ADVICE AND
CONSENT SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. WE DEFINITELY WE TAKE
SERIOUSLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HEAR FROM. A PANEL ON
VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES OF WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AND THIS
COMMITTEE THEN HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ASK QUESTIONS
OF MISTER POTTER WHO HAS BEEN A
COLLEAGUE OF OURS FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS. BYE WE WILL BE
LOOKING OBVIOUSLY AT OUR
COLLEAGUE THROUGH A VERY
DIFFERENT LANDS AT THIS POINT.
GIVEN THAT HE IS POTENTIALLY ON
THE CUSP OF TAKING A
CONSTITUTIONAL RULE. HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE THIS
ASSEMBLY HAS HAD. LONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PREVIOUS.
ATTORNEYS GENERAL. AND WHO HAD
WE SEE HONORING BASIS AND BY
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO ON A FAIRLY
BASIS AS WE WERE THROUGH PA
ISSUES THAT IMPORTANT TO THE TO
A GENERAL I THINK FOR MISTER BY
WE CERTAINLY HIS WORK ON THIS.
WHICH GIVING A BUT HOPEFULLY
GIVES US SOME IN WHAT TO EXPECT
BUT YET AS A LEADER OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL AGENCY WE LOOK
TO BE ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THAT AGENCY AND ENSURE THAT OUR
RELATIVE ROLES OF LEGISLATIVE
AND ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITY ARE LEADING TO
APPROPRIATE GOVERNANCE OF OUR
GREAT STATE AND I CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING
LOOK FORWARD TO THE RESPONSES
TO THE QUESTIONS AS WE
DELIBERATE ON WHAT WE FEEL ARE
APPROPRIATE NEXT STEPS SO THIS
WATER THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
YOUR HELP CHAMBERS AT THIS
POINT. AND TAKE THE RESPOND
RIGHT PARTICULAR TO THE THAT WE
PUT UP THERE ALREADY THAT IS
PART. OF OUR PUBLIC RECORD. AND
AS A FORWARD TO HAVE THE
COVERAGE. HE IN OUR CHAMBERS AS
WE THEN THOSE. WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE MAKING A WRECK. TO THE
ENTIRE BY. EARLY SAID SO YOU
MISTER CULTURE THANK YOU AND I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY TAKING A
SPEAKERS. APPOINTING ME AND MY
CO CHAIR STIRS. FOR THIS.
COMMITTEE HEARING ON HIS
NOMINEE PROP FOR CHEN. I'VE
BEEN IN ITS FOR NOW YEARS AND
IT TO PROVE. TO WORK WITH OUR
TO PAY A GENERAL. NOW VICE
HARRIS. AT NOW SECRETARY BASSIR.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A CALL A GREAT
NUMBER OF THINGS TO DURING THAT
TIME ONE NEED NOT LOOK TOO MUCH
THAN OVER A HUNDRED LOS FILED
BY ATTORNEY GENERAL BECERRA
AGAINST THE PREVIOUS. MINUTES
THE SEATTLE THIS OFFICE IS IN
PART THE RIGHTS AND FREEDOM. WE
CALIFORNIA HOLD. WE WILL HEAR
TO FOR EXPERTS IN PRACTICE AND
WE VARIETY OF ISSUE. WHO WILL
SPEAK TO THE SHE VOLUME FOR WE
HOLD IT TURNS RESP. AT THE
STATE TOP RETURN WINTRUST IS
OFFICE WOULD RESPONSE SUCH AS
HELPING ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY
THE PROTECTION OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
ENFORCING BERMAN REGULATIONS
PROVIDING IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION WHILE WE HAVE MADE
MANY GREAT STRIDES OR INTO THE
LAST NINE YEARS THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE. OUR ARMED
CONTRIBUTED SIX PERSONS PROGRAM
APPS THAT WAS DESIGNED TO KEEP
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
DANGERS FOR INDIVIDUALS IT'S
NOT ONLY. UNDERPERFORMING BUT
IS AT A RECORD BACKLOG IN THE
PAST YEAR WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
AN INCREASE OF OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE ADDED TO THE
APPS 417% INCREASE IN BACKLOG
OVER TWENTY TWENTY. TO RECENT
MASS SHOOTINGS IN THE CITY
FORESTER LEFT FOUR PEOPLE DEAD
PLACED ON APPS. HE WAS APPS
ELIGIBLE BASED ON PREVIOUS
CHARGES BUT FELL THROUGH THE
CRACKS. CLEARLY WE HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO MORE IMPORTANT THE
VERDICT DELIVERED YESTERDAY. IN
A DIRECTION TRIAL UNDERSCORES
WITH COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
LONG REQUESTED. ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR BAD OFFICERS. WHAT WE HAVE
pACCOMPLISHED A LOT AS A
LEGISLATURE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS OF BILLS TO CHANGE THE
USE OF. FORCE STANDARDS
INCREASE OFFICER TRAINING AND
MAKE OFFICER MORE SENSIBLE TO
PUBLIC PUBLIC WE WILL RELY.
HEAVILY RELY ON A JOURNEY
GENERAL JUST AS A BACK.
IMPROVEMENT FINAL ARBITER IN
CASES OF A PROMISED BY LAW. TO
MAKE. DIED HAVE DE FOREVER ALL.
BY THE ACTIONS OF BAD LAW.
OFFICIALS THE NATIONAL OUTCRY
FOR JUST IN THE DRAWER FLOYD
ONLY TO HAVE ANOTHER YOUNG. THE
I. DAVE. DIE THE SAME THE SAME
ON. AS THE VERDICT SHOWS WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO. THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE ATTORNEY.
MUST WORK IMPORTANCE TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS IT'S
OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OF JUSTICE. AS A TOOL TO DO JOB
WAS STAY VIGILANT REVIVAL. WHEN
HE- IS UNDER. I FORWARD TO THIS
TODAY. DEAR MR BONTA ABOUT US.
GOAL AND HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THE- OF ALL. THANK
YOU. SO MUCH BONTA YOU MAY
BEGIN. WHATEVER YOU'RE READY
WITH YOUR OPEN STATE. THANK YOU
CHAIRED SAWYER THANK YOU CARE
STONE YOU TELL MY ON THE- THANK
YOU COULD LEGISLATE THANK YOU
TEST AFTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY FOR OUR CON.
I ALSO WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO.
NEW FOR THE FAITH AND TRY THAT
HE HAS PLAY IN ME. AND I WANT
TO COME TO FIND TO. MY WIFE MIA
WHO IS HERE MY PER IN LIFE MY
PARTNER SERVICE- WHO IS PRESENT
WITH. MY PARENTS ARE ACTIVISTS
TO THEIR CORE. FIERCE FORCES
FOR FAIRNESS AND HER FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE HAS BEEN HARDWIRED INTO
WHO I AM. AFTER BLOODY SUNDAY
MY DAD HEADED TO SELMA ALABAMA
AS A COLLEGE STUDENT TO STAND
WITH MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
AND ORGANIZE FOR VOTING RIGHTS
AND FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. AS A
YOUNG FAMILY MOVED TO LET US
THE HEADQUARTERS OF THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS OF AMERICA
MOVEMENT. IN THE TAXI MOUNTAINS
OUTSIDE OF BAKERSFIELD. MY
PARENTS HAVE BEEN RECRUITED TO
HELP FILIPINO. LATINO
FARMWORKERS ADVOCATE FOR BETTER
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
AND THEY WORK ALONGSIDE DOLLARS
WHERE TAXES ARE CHAVEZ AND
PHILIP VERACRUZ. MOST OF ALL
WHAT IS STUCK WITH ME. ARE THE
LESSONS ABOUT THE QUALITY THAT
LA PAZ TAUGHT ME. IN THE PAST
IT DIDN'T MATTER AFTER DALLAS
AS A CHAVEZ. OR MIGRANT WORKER.
IT DIDN'T MATTER IF YOUR
FILIPINO. CHANNEL BLACK. OR
WHITE EVERYONE THOUGHT AND
JUSTICE IN THE WORLD. AND
WANTED TO FIX IT. I FAMILY
LAUGH APARTMENT WAS TIME FOR MY
BROTHER NEED TO START SCHOOL.
BUT THOSE EARLY LESSONS WITH
DON. THAT AND INJUSTICE AGAINST
ONE. IS AN INJUSTICE AGAINST
ALL. THAT'S WHY I DECIDED TO
BECOME AN ATTORNEY. TO FIGHT
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGED. WE'RE SCARED WE'RE
HURT. WERE MISTREATED. AND
NEEDED SOMEONE TO FIGHT FOR
THEM. AND IT'S NOT FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THAT MOTIVATES ME TODAY. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM LAW SCHOOL AND
SPENDING A SHORT TIME AND
PRACTICE. I DECIDED TO PRACTICE
FOR THE PEOPLE FULL TIME.
JOINING THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AS A DEPUTY
CITY ATTORNEY. I DID THAT FOR
NEARLY A DECADE BEFORE
ULTIMATELY JOINING YOU ALL IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. FOR THE
PAST EIGHT PLUS YEARS I'VE BEEN
EXCITED TO WAKE UP EVERY DAY
AND HIT THE GROUND RUNNING.
WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE OF THIS
GREAT STATE. IN THIS LIKE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE. I'VE BEEN
PROUD TO PARTNER WITH EACH OF
YOU. TO PASS A NUMBER OF MAJOR
REFORMS. AND TO RIGHT HISTORIC
WRONGS. TO REPAIR OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. TO TAKE ON BIG
POLLUTERS. AND PROTECT RENTERS.
HOMEOWNERS CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS. NUMBER TWO I'M
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF THE WORK
WE'VE DONE AND CONTINUE TO DO.
TO COMBAT HATRED AND HELP
VICTIMS OF HATE CRIME SO
IMPORTANT TODAY. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED LEADERS WHO WILL
BUILD BRIDGES WITH THOSE WHO
BEEN PERSECUTED. OTHER AND
TARGETED. THAT WOULD BE ONE OF
MY FIRST PRIORITIES ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE HONOR TO BE
CONFIRMED. TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
WHO ARE TARGETED BY THE FORCES
OF HATE. ARE PROTECTED. AND
THAT THOSE WHO USE HATE
VIOLENCE. ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
STRENGTHENING OUR DEFENSES
AGAINST HATE. IS NOT THE ONLY
PROBLEM WE FACE. THERE ARE
STILL TOO MANY WHO ARE WRONG IN
CALIFORNIA. TOO MANY TO BECOME
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING ABUSE.
AND MISTREATMENT. TOO MANY WHO
ARE TREATED UNFAIRLY BY THE
MANY BROKEN PARTS. OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
DESERVE MORE JUSTICE. MORE
HUMANITY AND A SECOND CHANCE.
TOO MANY HAVE BEEN CHEATED BY
BIG CORPORATIONS OR LIED TO. AS
PART OF AN ORGANIZED SCAM. OR
FRAUD. AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THESE FIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
FIGHTS WILL BE MY FIGHTS. I
KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGING CHALLENGES FACING
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BUT
I'M ALSO KEENLY AWARE OF THE
DEDICATION OF THE CAREER STAFF
AND THE TREMENDOUS WORK THAT IS
DONE. BY THE DEPARTMENT
EVERYDAY. THESE ARE SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST LEGAL MINDS IN
CALIFORNIA WORKING INCREDIBLY
HARD. EVERY DAY. TO PROTECT OUR
FAMILIES. CALIFORNIA DOJ MUST
BE AN ORGANIZATION THAT USES
MORE JUSTICE MORE HUMANITY.
MORE FAIRNESS AND MORE SAFETY.
INTO OUR INSTITUTIONS. HAVE TO
INFER I HOPE TO FURTHER ADVANCE
THOSE EFFORTS AND SOLIDIFIED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
REPUTATION. AS A NATIONAL
VANGUARD REFORM. WITH THAT I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
IN OUR CONVERSATION. THE AB SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE OW IS A
SERIES OF INDIVIDUALS EVER
RESPOND TO THE EIGHT TO SEE-
TOPICS THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER- YOUR PERSPECTIVES ON
WHAT YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
SHOULD BE ON AS A NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THAT WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT. SO
WE WILL BEGIN ON ITEM A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. MANOHAR RAJU SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDED-
OPERATOR. COULD YOU BRING IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER. AND ALSO WE ALSO MADE
ATTEMPTS TO ASK. DIFFERENT
PEOPLE COMING FROM BOTH SIDES
OF AN ISSUE SOME DECLINE MOST
DECLINE AND SO THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT WANTED TO RESPOND BUT WE
DID MAKE AN EFFORT. TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR BOTH SIDES OF AN ISSUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN GO AHEAD OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE SEVEN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION MY NAME IS
BUT- RAJU AND I'M DELIGHTED
PUBLIC DEFENDER A SEPARATE
CISCO. I'M HONORED TO REPRESENT
THE CRIMINAL DEFENSE COMMUNITY
AND THE MOVEMENT FOR TRUE AND
TRANSFORMATIVE JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO BEGIN
TODAY WITH THE GUILTY VERDICT.
RETURNED BY THE JURY THE
DIRECTIONAL CONTROL YESTERDAY.
TO BE CLEAR THE JURY REACHED
THE RIGHT DECISION. BUT AS
OTHERS HAVE SAID. THIS ISN'T
JUST THIS. JEFF THIS IS GEORGE
FLOYD BEING ALIVE TODAY.
JUSTICE IS ENDING POLICE
VIOLENCE AGAINST BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. JEFF THIS IS
DIVERTING RESOURCES FROM POLICE
TO PROGRAMS THAT WILL HELP
THOSE COMMUNITIES DEPRIVED. A
GUILTYVERDICT HERE PROVIDE
SOME MEASURE OFACCOUNTABILITY
BUT IT IS FAR SHORT OF JUSTICE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS OUTCOME WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN POSSIBLE IT KEEPS ALISON
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MINNESOTA
NOT STEPPED IN TO HANDLE THE
CASE. SIMPLY PUT IF THIS
PROSECUTION HAD BEEN BUT TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT DIRECTION
OF AND LIKELY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED. IN THE PAST
YEARS OUR COUNTRY HAS AWAKENED
TO THE FREQUENCY AND BRUTALITY
OF POLICE VIOLENCE AND JUST
THIS WEEK WE STATED AGAIN. THE
KIA BRYANT KILLED BY POLICE
JUST AFTER THE SHOWN VERDICT
WAS ANNOUNCED. AND MARIO
GONZALEZ KILLED MONDAY DURING A
WORK IN A REST BY THE ALAMEDA
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND AGAIN WE
WONDER. WE KNOW THE TRUTH OF
WHAT HAPPENED. IF THE
VERIFICATION REVEALS WRONGDOING
WILL IT BE SWEPT UNDER THE RUG.
OR WILL IT BE BROUGHT TO LIGHT.
IT'S CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABILITY BE A
TOP PRIORITY OF THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THIS
RESPONSIBILITY ALSO EXTENDS
BEYOND THESE MOST EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES IN INTO ROOTING
OUT RACIST BIASED AND BISLETT
SUBCULTURES WITHIN THE RANKS.
IT IS NOT JUST IMPORTANT THAT
THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL STEP
UP ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUES. THEY
MUST ALSO STEP DOWN WHEN PUSH
TO DEPEND ON JUST AN INMATE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE AND LOCAL
PROSECUTORS. HISTORICALLY
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S A
BIGGER SAY CONSISTENTLY FOUGHT
AGAINST THE APPEALS AND
PETITIONS OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE CHALLENGING WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS OR ANY MADE PRISON
CONDITIONS. THIS INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
CONTINUED DEFENSE OF EVERY
DEATH SENTENCE. REFUSAL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE STRONG INNOCENCE
CLAIMS RACIAL BIAS IN THESE
DECISIONS OR THE FACT THAT MANY
PEOPLE ON DEATH ROW SUFFER FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS IT INCLUDES THE
WAY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE'S DEFENDED THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION TO ACTION. WHICH
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DEATHS OF
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE PEOPLE
IN CDCR CUSTODY SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC. THE
PHYSICIANS IN THE VACATION
RELATED TO CRIMINAL APPEALS THE
DEATH PENALTYPRISON CONDITIONS
AND MORE ARE IN THE HUBEYSAN.
THERE SHAMEFUL. WE BELIEVE IT
IS POSSIBLE FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO FULFILL ITS
OBLIGATION TO REPRESENT THE
STATE NEEDS ACCESS WITHOUT
FURTHER DEGRADING THE HUMAN
BEINGS AT THE CENTRE OF THE
ISSUE AND WE CALL UPON THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL. TO MAKE IT SO.
FINALLY I WANT TO KNOW A FEW
OTHER THINGS THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL TAKING A KEY LEADERSHIP
ROLE ON. CLEAN STATE EFFORTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
THE MOST POWER AND
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MAINTAINING
AND EXPUNGING CRIMINAL RECORDS.
CALIFORNIA IS READY FOR A NEW
MORE EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE AND
FAIR APPROACH. WE URGE THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL. ROLE TO TAKE
A STRONG POSITION REGARDING
ENDING THE PRACTICE OF TURNING
PEOPLE OVER TO ICE. AFTER
THEY'VE EARNED THEIR RELEASED
FROM JAIL AND PRISON. IF
CONFIRMED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL BOTTAS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AT THE
INTERSECTION OF THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM AND PRIVATE
INDUSTRY BY ENSURING THAT RE
ELIMINATE THE PREDATORY BAIL
BONDS INDUSTRY. AND CONTINUE TO
MOVE AWAY FROM USING PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTERS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND TAKING
POWERFUL AND REFRESHING STANCES
REGARDING VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
ASIAN. THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS BY
RECOGNIZING THE PUNISHMENT IS
NOT THE ONLY POSSIBLE TOOL AND
OFTEN NOT THE BEST SOLUTION. TO
THESE PROBLEMS. THIS IS A
UNIQUE MOMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR STATE AND COUNTRY. PEOPLE
ARE READY FOR TRUE CHANGE IN
THE CORAL ECOSYSTEM IN A WAY
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE. IF
CONFIRMED ATTORNEY GENERAL
BONTA HAS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEIZE THAT
MOMENTUM MOMENTUM GENERATED BY
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
SYSTEM AND THEIR ALLIES TO
TRULY TRULY AND MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESSED THE SYSTEM'S
FAILURES. TO PROMOTE TO JUSTICE
CREW CUT ABILITY TO PUBLIC
SAFETY HEALTH AND HEALING. I
ALONG WITH MY OFFICE WILL BE
HERE TO SUPPORT HIM IN THESE
EFFORTS AND TO HELP KEEP HIM
ACCOUNTABLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FIVE MINUTES ON
THE DOT- NOT CIVIL RIGHTS
IMMIGRATION. ANGELICA SALAS A
COALITION OF HUMAN AND A HUMAN
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON A TEAM CO CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON THE OFFICE OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL MY NAME IS AND
HE GOT A LESSON ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHT. BETTER KNOWN AS- SURELY
THE MATH NUMBER SHIP DATE WHY
OR- OF IMMIGRANTS WITH NATIONAL
IMPACT I'M HERE TODAY. TO
EXPRESS. CHIRLA SUPPORT. FOR
THE COMBINATION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA A CALIFORNIA
NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL. IN A
NORMAL YEAR CALIFORNIA'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF CATHOLIC
DEPORTMENT OF BIG BOSS. THE
OVERSIGHT OF STATE LEGAL
SERVICES LEGAL REPRESENTATION
OF THE STATE AND THE OVERSIGHT
OF ONE. ACRE HOWEVER TWENTY
TWENTY AND EVEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HAVE NOT. BEEN NORMAL
YEARS. THE INCOMING ATTORNEY
GENERAL MUST BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. THAT HAVE ARISEN
FROM THE DEADLY COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. A DEVASTATING
RECESSION FOR WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN. A HISTORIC CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AGAINST SYSTEMIC
RACIS AND A DISTURBING RISE IN
HATE CRIMES AGAINST IMMIGRANTS
AND ASIAN AMERICANS. MR BONTA
IS WELL QUALIFIED TO CONFRONT.
THESE CHALLENGES. AND TO BEAT
THEM SOLUTION GROUNDED THE- ACT
FAIRNESS AND- RESPECT FOR CIVIL
AND HUMAN RIGHTS. MR BONTA
PERSON HISTORY. CONNECTIONS THE
STRUGGLE FACED BY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA HE IS
THE SON OF PROUD FILIPINO
PARENTS IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AND STOOD WITH DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR. IN
THE DEEP SOUTH. IF PARENTS BOTH
WORKED WITH THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS AND WERE ACTIVE AN
ONGOING FIGHT FOR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE HIS
PARENTS WORK. AND EMPLOYMENT
EXPIRED IF IT HAPPENED FIRED A
COMMITMENT TO HELPING PEOPLE
AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT COMMAND
COMMITMENT CORRECT CAN'T.
DURING THAT TIME THE ASSEMBLY
MR BONTA BETWEEN PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF THE CALIFORNIA VALUES
ACT SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR.
SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR
INSURANCE OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS FEEL SAFE
ACCESSING VITAL SERVICES
INCLUDING AT SCHOOLS HOSPITALS
AND COURT ROOM. THIS IS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION ROOTED IN
CALIFORNIA VALUES. MR BONTA
ALSO AUTHORED AB THIRTY TWO A
FIRST OF ITS KIND LAW THAT
PHASED OUT THE USE OF PRIVATE
PRISONS AND IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS MOMENT
EVERYTHING GROWING NUMBERS OF
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN ARRIVING
IN OUR STATE WE APPLAUD MR
BONTA FOR HIS FOURTH BACK TO
CLOSELY COLLABORATE WITH
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT
THE FLORES AGREEMENT TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN IT'S UP HEALTH. AND TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO ENSURE THESE
CHILDREN ARE PROTECTED AND
TREATED WITH THE UTMOST CARE.
HOWEVER WE MUST ALSO PROVIDE
KNOW YOUR RIGHTS EDUCATION
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT FOR THE
PARENTS OF THESE CHILDREN THEY
MUST BE GIVEN SUPPORT. AND
FAITH IN THE FACE OPPORTUNITY
TO READING MY WITH THEIR-
MISTER BONTA- HAS ASSURED THAT
BUT IF COMFORT HE WILL BE
PEOPLE TO TURN AND THAT WILL
STAND FOR CAL. FOR ALL. AND
FIGHTING THE DEATH. HE HAS ALSO
COME TO BE A VOICE THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND STATE THE
CONNECTION COMMUNITY IS VITAL
TO THE ROLE THE STATE OF
GENERAL I. OF AND NOT
COMMUNITIES ARE OFTEN THE. IN A
BUNCH GROUP THAT ACTORS.
POLICING I'M JOHN IN A GREAT
POLICY. AND PRACTICES. I HAD NO
DOUBT THAT IF. MR BY. WILL RISE
TO MEET EACH OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAD A HIM I DEFINE THE-
THAT ARE. IN AND- WITH
COMMUNITIES. HIS LEGAL
EXPERTISE LEADERSHIP IN THE
STATE. AND COMMIT TO COOK ABOUT
MAKING- THE PREMIUM. FOR THE-
POSITION WE ASK YOU THAT YOU.
MISTER CON. AND WANT TO CONFIRM
WE ARE READY WORK WITH HIM TO A-
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS ERIC.
ALTHOUGH CAL. IRRESPECTIVE OF
THEIR IN. STATUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL ENVIRONMENT
JUST. OF TV SETON LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU CHAIR
THANK YOU COMMITTEE- THINKING
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE ARE A
COMMUNITY BASED ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN IN COACHELLA VALLEY
FOCUSED ON THE AREA THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE CLIMATE
CHANGE CLEAN ENERGY SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
DRINKING WATER ACCESS TO
GROUNDWATER PROTECTION- IN
SHORT ALL THE THINGS THAT MAKE
US SAFE- AS CALIFORNIANS ARE
SHOULD MAKE US ALL SAFER OF
CALIFORNIANS. THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS SHOWN US THE
POTENTIAL AND POWER OF THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND FURTHERING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE HOUSING JUSTICE AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE GENERALLY. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MR
BONTA AND HIS TEAM TO ADVANCE
THESE GOALS. WE HAVE WORKED
SUCCESSFULLY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND IN
PARTICULAR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BUREAU TO INCREASE
SCRUTINY OF LOCAL LAND USE
PLANNING AND SITING DECISIONS.
WE WORK IN NEIGHBORHOODS
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY AIR
POLLUTION TRAFFIC WHICH
FACILITIES AND CONTAMINATED
WATER. IT HAS BEEN OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE EXPERIENCE OF
OTHERS THAT WITHOUT
INTERVENTION BY COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND ADVOCATES THE
PATTERNS OF CONCENTRATING
HARMFUL AND USES CONTINUOUS AND
WITH IT THE CONCENTRATION OF
HARMFUL AND USES. AND LOWER
INCOME BLACK INDIGENOUS. AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR COMMUNITIES. IN
JUST BUREAU HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ADDING WEIGHT
TO COMMUNITY CLAIMS THAT JUST
BECAUSE BUSINESS AS USUAL THE
BUSINESS'S USUAL. THAT DOESN'T
MAKE IT LEGAL. WE ALONG WITH
COLLEAGUES IN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. CONTINUE TO
HOLD LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
HUMAN RIGHTS WHEN DECIDING
WHERE AND HOW TO DEVELOP IN
WHERE AND HOW TO PLAN FOR
INSIGHT UNDESIRABLE NEIGHBORS.
SIMILARLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MR BONTA AND HIS
TEAM TO HOLD POLLUTERS
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION LAWS SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFE WATER TO
DRINK AND CLEAN AIR TO BREATHE.
ON A RELATED NOTE THERE IS A
GROWING NEED AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS INCREASED AUTHORITY
TO PROMOTE ACCESS TO SAFE AND
SECURE HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. WE HOPE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL PLAY A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN ENSURING
THAT STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
ALL OF THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING. OUR EXPERIENCE OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS IT'S NOT
ONLY THAT ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HAS DECREASED BUT THAT
TREND IN BOTH LAND USE AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION ARE FAVORING
EXCLUSIVE HIGHER INCOME
DEVELOPMENTS. EXACERBATING BOTH
THE EXPORTABLE HOUSING AND FAIR
HOUSING CRISES FACING CALLAHAN
CITIES IN INLAND CALIFORNIA. WE
HOPE TO WORK WITH MR BONTA
SCHEME TO ENSURE IMPLEMENTATION
OF HOUSING ELEMENT AND OTHER
PLANNING TOOLS THAT FURTHER
FAIR HOUSING AND NEED HUGE GAP
AND SAFE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACCESS. TO LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. OKAY ADDITION.
UNFORTUNATELY SEEN INCREASES
AND HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION
OF VULNERABLE TENANTS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND WE- AGAIN
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO INTERVENE IN THE
CASE OF AN INTIMIDATING
PRACTICES. DESIGNED TO SKIRT A
GROWING BODY OF TENANT
PROTECTION LAWS. DESPITE
RHETORIC CELEBRATING ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THIS PAST YEAR WE HEARD
OF MORE WORKER ABUSES IN
AGRICULTURE IN THE PAST YEAR
THAN WE HAD EVER HEARD BEFORE.
LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH WORKER
PROTECTION MANDATE INTIMIDATION
AND HUMILIATION ESPECIALLY IN
THE MIDST OF WILDFIRE AND
COVERT AMERICAN CHEESE TOPPED
THE LIST OF WHAT WE HEARD WE
URGE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
CHEATED THE AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE TEAM PRESS ONE FOR SORTS
FOR PROTECTION. AND WORKERS
RIGHTS. A ON A NOTE THAT NEED
PROCEED AS SERVE FROM THE COGER.
OF ADMISSIONS NON. DOING ITS
VERY BEST TO RESOURCE OUR STAFF
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
OFFICIALS WILLING TO CHANGE THE
WORLD FOR THE BETTER WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE ACUTE IMPACTS OF
THE PANDEMIC. WE HOPE TO SEE MR
FONG BONTA AND HIS ROLE AS A
REGULATOR OF ALL CHARITIES IN
THE STATE. PUSH FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND MORE
AGGRESSIVE AN EQUITABLE
INVESTMENTS IN NON PROFITS
THANKS A LOT SALANTER P. AND
DONOR ADVISED FUND SPONSORS.
EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIANS SPEND
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FORM OF
CHARITABLE DEDUCTIONS TO DONOR
ADVISED FUNDS THAT HAVE NO
REQUIREMENTS RELEASE THOSE
FUNDS TO ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
HARD AND COMMUNITY.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS. WE
HOPE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL USES.
OR AIR AND WE HOPE YOU WILL USE
IT TO ENSURE CHERUB FUNDS GOING
TO SIT THERE INTENDED PURPOSE.
HELPING PEOPLE AND HELPING
NEIGHBORHOODS. THANK YOU AGAIN
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE PRIVILEGE
OF SPEAKING TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU MISTER BONTA TO
CREATE ONE FAIR AND ONE JUST
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. NOW WILL
HAVE FROM THE CONSUMER SIDE.
THE N. TRENTON CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PLAN TRITON SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING US. THE CRITICAL
ROLE OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND TO LEAD ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST THOSE WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CALIFORNIANS. AT A
TIME A POWERFUL CORPORATE
INTERESTS FREQUENTLY LEVERAGE
THEIR POWER TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CONSUMERS. AND OUR COURTS
ARE FACING A BACKLOG ONE POINT
TWO MILLION CASES WILL GROWING.
AND AS HATE CRIMES HAVE REACHED
A FEVER PITCH WE NEED AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO IS NOT
AFRAID TO TAKE ON BIG FIVE.
ALONG THE PATH THROUGH THE BODY
ARMENIAN LANDS THEY ARE NOT
ENFORCED. ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
FORSMAN OFTEN PARTNERED WITH
LEGAL ACTION FOR THE DOUBLE
BAR. IS A CRITICAL PART OF
MAKING SURE THAT LAWS ARE
FOLLOWED. CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL HAVE
BROAD ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY IN
MANY AREAS. SUCH AS PROTECTING
OUR ELDERS FROM ABUSE. THE
CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SUPPORTING. LEGISLATION
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE BY MAJORITY
LEADER RAY AS TO STRENGTHEN
THOSE LAWS. ETERNIA CHANNEL
ALSO HELPS THEM OPIOID
ADDICTION BY MONARCH MONITORING
EXPENSIVE PRESCRIBING THROUGH
THE CHORES DATABASE. THEY CAN
PROHIBIT AND FIGHT UNFAIR AND
FRAUDULENT BUSINESS PRACTICES
BY POLLUTERS CONTAMINATE OUR
AIR AND WATER. BACK DOWN
UNDERSTAND OF DANGEROUS
PRODUCTS LIKE MERCURY
CONTAINING CREAMS SOLD THROUGH
ONLINE MARKETPLACES. WORKING
WITH WHISTLEBLOWERS WHO OUT OF
ACTION AND PROTECT THE STATE TO
THE FALSE CLAIMS STATUTE. AND
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL ISSUES
OF OUR TIME AGAIN CAN HELP BY
LISTENING TO MOST OF US ON THE
PANEL. THE FIGHTING RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION AND ALL OF ITS
FORMS IT'S PAST ONLY AS IT
RELATES TO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND ENFORCEMENT
CRIMINAL LAW. WE'VE LEARNED
FROM WATCHING THE TRIAL AGAINST
ART SHOW THEN UNFOLD THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TOP COTTON NINE
HAVE THE COURAGE OF THEIR
CONVICTIONS TO HOLD OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE. WHEN THEY VIOLATE
THE LAWS THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
ENFORCE. WE KNOW WHERE BOB
PAKISTAN'S. HE HAS SAID IN
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IF
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS BREAK THE
LAW WE MUST HAVE TOOLS TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE- HE IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AS LONG AS
CALIFORNIA'S CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS ARE SET TO SPLIT
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ENJOY ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY FROM
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
ACTIONS THEY WILL STRUGGLE TO
HOLD OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE. ALL
AT THE CO AUTHOR OF SENATE BILL
TO ROB BONTA BACKING UP HIS
WORDS WITH ACTION. WORKING TO
SHARPEN OUR STATE CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS DEPENDS TOLD BY
YEARS OF BAD COURT DECISIONS
THAT FAVOR OFFICER THE UNITY OF
OUR CHAPTER. CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
HAS WORKED ALONGSIDE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA ON
IMPORTANT CIVIL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL JUSTICE LEGISLATION
SPANNING NEARLY A DECADE. FROM
TAKING ON THE LEAD PAINT
INDUSTRY AND WHEN IN PITCH
STRENGTHENING IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THOSE HARMED BY
POLICE MISCONDUCT. ROB BONTA
HISTONE AND I'M WAVERING
WILLINGNESS TO SPEAK TRUTH TO
POWER AND TO HOLD BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE. WE BELIEVE ROB
BONTA IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO
WIELD THE TREMENDOUS POWER OF
THE OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ENFORCE OUR LWS.
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
STRENGTHEN THEM MY CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT FALL SHORT THE
LEVELS THAT CONSUMER PROTECTION
IN THE STATE. IN REALITY. THAT
OUR CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
ONLY AS STRONG AS THE LEADERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OPERATING AT.
AT THE CURRENT AND SOON TO BE
FORMER MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE. CONFIDENT THAT IS
OUR NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL. ROB
BONTA WILL HAVE EVEN MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE
LAWMAKERS ON IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. CONSUMER TRADE PUT
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ROB
BONTA OVER THE COMING YEAR. TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. STRENGTHENED
THE LOW RISE AND KEEP THE DOORS
OF CHAPTER WIDE OPEN FOR EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF WHO THEY ARE. WHERE THEY
COME FROM OR WHO THEY LOVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND. NOW
BARBARA IS A SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
I WILL COMMIT FOR YOU FOR THEY
ALL IN UNDER FIVE MINUTES-
THAT'S PRETTY DARN IMPRESSIVE
BUT NOT TO PUT A WHOLE LOT OF
PRESSURE ON BILL C. CONNECT-
FROM THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION OUR LAST SPEAKER.
THANK YOU. I'LL DO MY BEST
DANDER FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR ASKING
ME TO PARTICIPATE TODAY I WANT
TO THANK YOU MR BONTA FOR YOUR
PAST SUPPORT OF INITIATIVE
AIMED AT EVERYTHING THE RAPE
KIT BACKLOG AND BETTERING THE
SYSTEM PER SURVIVORS. FINDING
THE FELT THE CONNECTION I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
ADVOCACY FOR THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR BY LAW AND ORDER
SVU ACTOR AND ADVOCATE MARISKA
HARGITAY FOR THE FIRST STATE
THAT CALIFORNIA UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN JOYFUL HEART
HAVE OFFICE FROM MY FANS OUT
THERE WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA WORKING FINE
STATUTES LIMITATIONS. REFORM
ADVOCATE BACKLOG. OUR FOUNDER-
SAYS THREE BACK ONE OF THE- OF
A LARGER. THE FAILURE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
DECIDED TO TAKE SEXUAL ASSAULT
SERIOUSLY. WE URGE THE NOMINEE
TO PLEDGE TO TAKE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SERIOUSLY AND TO
PRIORITIZE THAT AS A VIOLENT
CRIME THAT IT IS. CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN SOME IMPORTANT STEPS
TO ADDRESS SEXUAL CALL BUT
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE THE STATE
LAGGED BEHIND. I WANT TO SHARE
AN EXAMPLE OF SPEAKS TO HOW THE
STATE HAS FALLEN SHORT. THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FORTY ALONG
WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY NANCY O'MALLEY. IT
HAPPENED JUST THE PROJECT AND
OF COURSE SENATOR LEYVA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER Q. FATHER
EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE EIGHT THE
CREATED A STATE WIDE INVENTORY
OF RICKETTS. INVENTORY BUT TO
BE CONDUCTED BY CAL. DOJ UNDER
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. TWENTY
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA AG
RELEASE INVENTORY. THAT SHOWED
THAT ONLY A HUNDRED FORTY NINE
POLICE AGENCIES AND CRIME LABS
PARTICIPATED IN THE AUTUMN.
THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE AGENCIES IN THE
STATE. NO MEDICAL FACILITY
PROVIDED INFORMATION. BECAUSE
OF THE INCOMPLETE INVENTORY WE
STILL DON'T KNOW THE FULL SCOPE
OF THE RAPE KIT BACKLOG IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SMALL NUMBER OF
AGENCIES THAT PARTICIPATED IN
THE AUDIT FOUND NEARLY FOURTEEN
THOUSAND UNTESTED KITS. HOW
MANY MORE COULD THERE BE. WHAT
IN THE AREA OF RATE CAN'T
REFORM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN
LEAD ON CONDUCTING A FULL SCALE
INVENTORY FUNTASTIC AT. AGE YOU
CAN ALSO PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN ENSURING THOSE UNTESTED
KITS. ARE FINALLY PROCESS. I
REMIND YOU EACH KIT REPRESENTS
A SURVIVOR WAITING FOR JUSTICE
AND DANGEROUS OFFENDERS TO A
MAINSTREAM TO HARM AGAIN. MANY
THAT ARE SERIAL OFFENDERS AND
COMMIT ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
SPECIAL ISSUE THE BLLOT THAT
THE AG CONTRACTOR THAT'S
IMPORTANT OFFICE. SEXUAL
ASSAULT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
SCHOOLS DRUG AND ALCOHOL
FACILITATED SEXUAL ASSAULT
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE. RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE RACIAL AND
GENDER BIAS IN POLICING SEX
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT. THE
INTERSECTION OF OTHER CRIMES
SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STALKING AND THE IMPACT ON
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. I'LL
NECESSITATE DEEP FOCUS AND
COMMITMENT. AGING THAT THE TOWN
OF POLICY FOR THE SPONSORED
CRYING. ESTATE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE ELIMINATE THE
BACKLOG AND CREATED A BETTER
SYSTEM FOR SURVIVORS RECEIVED
STRONG VISIBLE LEADERSHIP AT
THE TOP. A DECADE LATER THAT
THAT WITH THE GOAL OF THE WORKS
OF ADVOCATES. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND RESEARCHERS TO SHIFT
APPROACHES. RICHARD AND CLEAR
ABOUT THE MISSION AND WHO IS
NOT AFRAID TO SHIP THE DIALOGUE
AND THE CULTURE THAT SURROUNDS
THIS CRIME. TECHIES AND APPLE.
AFTER FIFTEEN THOUSAND UNTESTED
RAPE KITS WERE DISCOVERED IN
NORTH CAROLINA ATTORNEY GENERAL
JOSH STEIN. PROPOSED THE
STANDING UP FOR RAPE VICTIMS
ACT THE BILL WASN'T ACTED THE
SAME YEAR. MANDATING LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE SENATE
ALL CANCER TESTING AN
ACCOUNTING SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLASH. THE
PREVIOUS NEVADA ATTORNEY
GENERAL ADAM LAXALT CREATED A
FLEXIBLE WORKING GROUP TO CRAFT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE STATE'S
BACK LIKE. THE CURRENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL AIRPORT ANNOUNCED LAST
YEAR. THAT NEVADA HAD
ELIMINATED THEIR BACK LOT. THE
ILLINOIS ATTORNEY GENERAL LISA
MADIGAN BUT IT EFFORT TO PASS A
LAW REQUIRING LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ADOPT EVIDENCE BASED. TRAUMA
INFORMED POLICIES. AND REQUIRED
SPECIALIZED TECHNICAL TRAINING
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. THE ENTUCKY
ATTORNEY GENERAL CREATED A NEW
UNIT AND HIS OFFICE TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
SEXUAL FELT COLD CASES. AND AT
THE ATTORNEY. GENERAL FOR OHIO
CREATED A SIMILAR UNIT. I
REGRET AND EFFECTIVE RESPONSE
TO SUCH A LOT OF THE HUGE LEFT
IT WILL TAKE STRONG LEADERSHIP
COMMITMENT AND INVESTMENT BY
THE STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JOYFUL HEART STRONGLY
RECOMMENDS THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AT THAT IS A NEAT
UNIQUE PROPOSITION RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSEEING AND ENFORCING
COMPLIANCE. WITH EXISTING
SEXUAL ASSAULT POLICIES. SO
THAT THINGS LIKE A STATEWIDE
AUDIT ARE BEAUTIFUL OPTIONAL.
ADDITION THAT WOULD SEE THE
LARGER PICTURE SUGGESTS
INNOVATIVE CHANGES. THE
POSITION WOULD CREATE A POINT
PERSON AT WORK THE VERY
AGENCIES ADDRESSING THE
VIOLENCE INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND EFFECTIVE IN THE MANAGEMENT
FIELD. PERHAPS THIS IS A LARGE
INITIATIVE MENTIONED IN A
RECENT HEALTH MATTERS ARTICLE.
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
AMONG THE FIRST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY MAYBE THE FIRST STATE
TO HAVE SUCH A DEDICATED
POSITION. IF CONFIRMED WE URGE
AG BONTA TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
LEADER ON A RATCHETING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AND CREATING BETTER
PATH TO JUSTICE FOR HEALING FOR
ALL SURVIVORS. WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND NOW I WILL TURN THE
CHAIRMANSHIP AND GAVEL OVER TO
BUY CO CHAIR- MY PARTNER
JUSTICE FROM THE CHAIR THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE. YOU MISTER
JONES SAWYER SO THE NEXT THREE
SEGMENTS WILL BE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AND THEN COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS IN DELIBERATIONS. AND
THEN WE WILL BE CLOSING THE
HEARING SO FOR PUBLIC OMMENT
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE. ONE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHARES
IN MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MR BONTA IS CONFIRMATION AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN
PRIVILEGED IN BEING ABLE TO
WORK WITH HIM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND CAN CERTAINLY ATTEST
TO HIS. REPRESENTING HIS
CONSTITUENTS QUITE WELL AND
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN PLEASED WITH
HIS OPEN DOOR POLICY AND HIS
WILLINGNESS TO TACKLE THE BIG
ISSUES AND WE KNOW THAT HE WILL-DO AN OUTSTANDING JOB SERVING
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. I
DON'T THINK SO HI WE NOW OPEN
UP UP OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE FIRST OPEN
LINE NUMBER EIGHT SIX THREE
NINE EIGHT SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS BARBARA
PLAYED THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED HOSPITAL AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE NOMINATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA IF
THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOSPITALS IN THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HAVE
WORKED WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEN
FOR YEARS TO ADVANCE AND
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. HE IS A
STRONG AND EFFECTIVE ADVOCATE
FOR EQUITY IN HEALTHCARE AND
EXPANDED ACCESS TO SERVICES FOR
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE
ARE PLEASED TO STAND TODAY
REPORTER. THIS NOMINATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR HOW MANY
COLORS IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE
FIFTEEN Q. CURRENTLY OKAY THEN
I'LL ALLOW BRIEF COMMENTS UP TO
TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU
NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER EIGHT SIX
FOUR NINE EIGHT SIX FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- THIS IS MIKE
HERALD WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. WE ARE ALSO
OUR CALL IN TONIGHT IN TO
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF A
MISTER MONTEZ CONNECTED DURING
GENERAL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- OVER HIS TIME
IN THE ASSEMBLY IN RECENT
YEARS. HE HAS BEEN A STAUNCH
CHAMPION FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. REPEATEDLY
WORKING ON BEHALF OF. OUR
CLIENT MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET
THE PUBLIC BENEFIT THE
HEALTHCARE ON THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE THAT THEY DESERVE. AND
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT HE
HAD BEEN ON ONE OF OUR
CHAMPIONS- ON ISSUES RELATED TO
ENDING THE HORRIFIC BAIL
PRACTICES THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ENGAGING IN
MANY YEARS FOR MANY YEARS. AND
THEN LASTLY- HE'S BEEN A LEADER
IN THE AREA OF PREVENTING
ADDICTIONS AND FIGHTING FOR
FAIRNESS FOR TENANTS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR MANY
YEARS WE THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
AN OUTSTANDING ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND OPEN
NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN. EIGHT SEVEN
THREE MIND IS NOW OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RAHUL KEY ON THE-
FORMER BOILED SCHOOL BOARD
PRESIDENT SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOXES
NOMINATION COULD BE OUR NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT ONE EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD EVENING CAN MEMBERS
ARE NOT BETTER BACK ON BEHALF
OF BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA
FTA YOU CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL NEXT IN CALIFORNIA TO
PICK A UNION CITY- TOOK COUNTY
INDIAN. NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND ENERGY ALL
OF TRUMP'S SUPPORTER OF THE
PHONE NUMBER ROB BONTA
NOMINATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANNEX TO OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHT SIXTY TWO ONE EIGHT SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS BENJAMIN
TRYING WHAT IS AN AMERICAN WHO
BACKS AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE LARGEST ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ON THEIR
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. WE ARE
PROUD TO CALL THE SENATE MEMBER
BONTA A NUMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND YES LONG
CHAMPIONED EXACT ISSUES TIME
AND TIME AGAIN. DIVIDE AN
EXAMPLE DATED BACK GIPSON HAS
BEEN ISSUE LONG POPCORN- FOR
THE P. ACTS MEANS WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOB THE PASSED
THROUGH AB SEVENTEEN OR TWENTY
SIX. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN. I DON'T WE CALLING
STATE FOR THE POINT. TO THE
ATTORNEY OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR LINE EIGHT FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
EVENING COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
NOMINEE BONTA LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT. YOU'RE A POLICY
ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS AND A
VOICE OF THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
IN CALIFORNIA. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
OVERSEEING NONPROFIT THAN AND
SUPPORTING POLICIES THAT HELP
THE SECTOR THRIVE. BASED ON OUR
CLOSE WORK WITH PRIOR ATTORNEY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WE RECOMMEND
FIVE NONPROFIT RELATED
PRIORITIES FOR THE NEW ATTORNEY
GENERAL. ONE IS BE PROACTIVE IN
PURSUIT OF SCAMMERS PRETENDING
TO BE NONPROFIT. SCAMMER DAMAGE
THE PUBLIC TRUST IN THE SECTOR.
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
REGULATIONS OF THE ONLINE
DONATION INDUSTRY TO HELP
INSURE THAT DONORS AND
RECIPIENT CHARITIES ARE
PROTECTED. THREE PROMOTE
POLICIES THAT STRENGTHEN
NONPROFITS AS KEY SERVICE
PROVIDERS EMPLOYERS AND
ECONOMIC DRIVERS NONPROFIT
EMPLOYED MORE THAN ONE POINT
TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
BRING IN MORE THAN FIFTY FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUT OF STATE
RESOURCES TO OUR STATE. AND FOR
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR DONOR ADVISED FUND. TO HELP
ENSURE THAT MORE OF THOSE FUNDS
GET TO NONPROFIT SERVING
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
FIVE SEEK OPPORTUNITIES TO
REMEDY RESOURCE. ARE THESE AND
OTHER INEQUITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. WE REALLY APPRECIATED
THE LONG STANDING WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE HAD
WITH THE DOJ'S CHARITABLE TRUST
DIVISION AND WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE THAT COLLABORATIVE
WORK WITH MR BONTA AT THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL. TO PROTECT
AND STRENGTHEN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THAT OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHT SIXTY NINE EIGHT
SIX NINE REMINDED NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS A LITTLE. I SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S CHOICE OF ROB BONTA
TO BE CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND AS PROP TO
SUPPORT THIS NOMINATION OF A
CHAMPION- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM FULLER INVESTING
CREATING SHARE SAFETY PAUL.
WELL BONTA DEMONSTRATED
CRITICAL LEADERSHIP AND
UPDATING THE STATE'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RECORDS SYSTEM WHILE HE
WAS IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
WELL AS ADDING ON. AND ON BAIL
REFORM. BANNING PRIVATE PRISONS
PROTECTING IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
AND ADVOCATING FOR THE CLIENTS
RATED INDIVIDUALS LIKES DURING
THE COLDER AND THEN. AND AFTER
FIRST EIGHT EIGHT ZERO NINE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CALIFORNIA
HE WILL BE A LEADER THAT BREAKS
LONG OVERDUE THERE YEARS AND
REFLECTS OUR DIVERSE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ENACTED
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHTY FIFTY
FIVE EIGHT FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME AT THE KEY HOP WITH
RESOLUTE ON BEHALF OF THE CAN
HE HAVE TRIED TO THE VA HAS
TRIED AND- ABOUT MUSCLE PULL
MORE PROPERLY TRIED. AS WELL AS
ON BEHALF OF MAGGIE Q.
EXPECTING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF A FAMILY
MEMBER ROB BONTA. AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR EIGHT
SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JOHNNY BEING THAT WOULD
CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF UCLA LATINO POLICY AND
POLITICS EIGHTY TWO. AND LIKE
LOOK AT THE ACCOUNT THAT YOU
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF MR BONTA CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT SEVENTY
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS JASON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN UNITED
TERRY'S AND THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION- THESE
CLIENTS THAT KNOWN AND WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE SUN NEVER
BONTA OVER THE YEARS AND ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT. HIS
CONFIRMATION TO BECOME THE NEXT
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
THANK YOU. I'D COULD OPEN LINE
NUMBER EIGHT SEVEN NINE EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD EVENINGS AFTER COVER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION SINCE JOINING THE
LEGISLATURE MR BONTA HAS BEEN A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND EQUITY. THE
RATE OF CALIFORNIANS AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM. ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBER DENTISTS. THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
IS PLEASED TO OFFER OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE HISTORIC
NOMINATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB
BONTA. ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND THAT OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE TO
REALIZE HOW ABOUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS AFRIKA
VARGAS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION IF AND THE
THIRTY SEVEN. MEMBER TRIED
SALFORD RECOGNIZED PROUD TO
SUPPORT DISTURBANCES
CONFIRMATION AS WELL AS THE
ARMENIAN TRADE IN LABOR
ASSOCIATION ORGANIZATION OF
ARMENIAN BUSINESS OWNERS
PREDOMINATELY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHT SIX SEVEN Y. EIGHT SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS THIS IS
JOSH KLINE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
HELLO WE STRONGLY ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND NOT REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE COVERAGE TO
SUPPORT INCARCERATED AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHT TWO ONE EIGHT
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD EVENING SHARE NUMBERS THIS
IS MARTIN DR RICH WITH WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING. ORGANISATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT- MISTER ROB
BONTA TERRITORY GENERAL THAT'S
CALIFORNIA YIMBY SPUR HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA.
SANDHILL TMG PARTNERS CASITA
COALITION THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL GREEN LINING INSTITUTE.
NAMED RALPH PRO CHOICE AND YOU
DIDN'T HEALTH DISTRICT ONCE
AGAIN UP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MR BONTA FIRST CONFIRMATION
KERN COUNTY GENERAL. THANK YOU
BYE THANK YOU. OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR NINE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES
CHAIRED FALLEN TREES ON BEHALF
THE COLUSA INDIAN COMMUNITY AND
I KNOW CHAIRMAN CARL FROM
DETERMINES TRYING TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORTING ROB BONTA AS A FAIR
AND EQUITABLE AG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX TO OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE ONE EIGHT
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS PROJECT MR
CO CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ACTUALLY SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE OVER TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
ACOSTA TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AT YOUR PLEASED TO SUPPORT
GOVERNOR NEEDS OF THE POINT
MAN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA
AND THE NEXT CALIFORNIA'S. NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO OPEN MY
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY SIX THE
LINE EIGHT EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THE CO CHAIR THE
MEMBERS LINE LONGER THAN A
PLATINUM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITIES THE CALIFORNIA
CARD ROOMS. WE NEED TO SUPPORT
THE CONFIRMATION AND SOME OF
THEM ROB BONTA AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL THANK YOU. THANK. I'D
LIKE TO OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT
NINETY NINE EIGHT NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MEMBERS
AND THE LAWS THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO GET THE IMPORTANT. H. AND
ALL WE WANTED TO POINT OUT HIS
STRONG WITH THREE AT THE PLATE
WITH A PILOT I AM ATTENTION.
ALL WE'VE BEEN OF GOING ABOUT
IT WE DON'T HAVE ONE AND THEN
ON A QUICK PERSONAL NOTE. JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT. WHAT A
PLATE FIVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGE
FOR THAT. THE THANK. OPEN
NUMBER A EIGHTY SEVEN LIKE
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN YEAR IS NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE AND CANONICA
CALLED IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY-
ABOUT BOX NUMBER. I THINK
GENERAL NINETEEN. BALLOTS
IMMIGRATION POLICY ADVISOR
FAMILY PRACTICE AND ADVOCATES
CALLING IN MY PERSONAL CAPACITY
I HAD THE DISTINCT PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH. ATTORNEY GENERAL
NOMINEE ROB BONTA ON CRITICAL
PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW
DOZENS OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND INDIVIDUALS JOIN ME FROM
THE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS MOVEMENT
IN APPLAUDING- A DATE ON. IT
THE HISTORIC MOMENT YOU'RE
TURNING GENERAL CALIFORNIA HAS
WITH THE UNIQUE POWERS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES MORE SO THAN
ANY OTHER STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T THERE'S NO BETTER PERSON
TO FILL POSITIONS AND RAPAT AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM. AND HIS NEXT CHAPTER IN.
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT OPEN NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHTY THREE LIKE EIGHT EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD EVENING COCHAIRED MEMBER
MACTECH A LOT OF THE- SILICON
VALLEY CAMPUS DURING STRONG
SUPPORT OF CONFIRMATION TO ROB
BONTA DISCOVERED NEXT TO
TRADITIONAL THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY SO I'LL ASK ONE MORE
TIME IF THERE'S ANYONE. IN THE
CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE TO. COMMENT
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE SEPARATE IF
YOU CAN MAKE ONE MORE REQUEST.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU BET YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. THE NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER
EIGHT NINE TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME'S RYAN CALLING
FROM UFCW LOCAL FIVE AND I
WANTED TO VOICE OUR
ORGANIZATION FULL AND VOCAL
SUPPORT FOR MR BONTA
APPOINTMENT TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARK THE CAR
ON THE TRAVEL CHANNEL THE CHINA
TREPIDATION TO MACULAR
CALIFORNIA WANTED TO CONVEY OUR
OUR SUPPORT FOR BONTA
CONFIRMATION- WE BELIEVE PEOPLE
BE A FAIR AND JUDICIOUS
ATTORNEY GENERAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHAT WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON AB CUTE UP BUT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR I WILL ASK IF ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER EIGHT NINE ONE.
BY EIGHT NINE ONE REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN EIGHT NINE ONE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CONNIE CAN JAIL I'M THE CEO OF
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES. AT I
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY- YEAR
ENDED YESTERDAY SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB BONTA AT THE NEXT
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING-
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS. EVEN
RESTAURANTS AND SUPPORTING THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY INCLUDING RIGHT NOW
DURING THIS TIME. AND PATIENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE WOULD USE
THEIR- K. OPERATOR ASK YOU ONE
MORE TIME TO JUST. ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT. CERTAINLY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE IF
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE TEN ZERO
ACTIVE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THREE THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE DID
PUBLIC COMMENT FIRST SO THAT
MEMBERS HAD EVERY OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR WHAT THE PUBLIC THINKS
BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP HERE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS IN OUR
DELIBERATIONS. SO NOW MEMBERS
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY MISTER
JONES SAWYER AND I HAD A TIME
TO ASK QUESTIONS AS WE PUT
TOGETHER A LETTER WHICH IS A
PART OF THE PACKAGE NOWSO I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MR BONTA MORE
COMMENTS AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ENSURE THAT IF YOU DO HAVE A
QUESTION MAKE SURE IT IS S. AS
A AS A QUESTION BUT YOU'RE ALSO
WELCOME TO MAKE COMMENTS AS
PART OF OUR DELIBERATIONS AND
OUR OFFICIAL RECORD. SO MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS OF MR BONTA WITHOUT.
DODD. THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. MR BONTA
THANK YOU FURTHER CONVERSATION
THEM I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
REACHED OUT TO EVERYONE OF US
AND HAD THOSE- INDIVIDUAL
CONVERSATION SO I'LL JUST GO
THROUGH MY WHICH YOU WERE AWARE
OF WHAT I'LL BE ASKING- THE
PROBLEM BILL OF ILLEGAL
MARIJUANA HAS BECOME QUITE
PRONOUNCE INTERVIEW TONIGHT THE
REGION I REPRESENT SPECIFICALLY
AND SISKIYOU COUNTY. THIS HAS
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS WERE
ENVIRONMENT. TOXIC ILLEGAL
PESTICIDES ARE BEING USED ON
THESE GROW SITES TO DESTROYING
ECO SYSTEMS RUNOFF FROM FIELDS
ARE POLLUTING OUR WATERWAYS AND
HABITAT FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES.
IT ALSO BRINGS SERIOUS PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS INCLUDING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZED CRIME
MONDAY MONEY LAUNDERING MANDIRA
LAUNDRY EXCUSE ME IN EXTREME
CASES HOMICIDES. AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL HOW TO ADDRESS
ORGANIZED CRIME THAT IS
ILLEGALLY CULTIVATING CANNABIS
AND ENDANGERING OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WILL YOU COMMIT TO WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ME AND
MULTI AGENCY TASK FORCE TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM IS SISKIYOU
COUNTY AND SURROUNDING AREAS.
THANK YOU AT THE FOREVER DAILY
FOR THEIR EARLIER CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD AND THE QUESTION
THAT YOU POSED YOU YOU RAISE AN
ISSUE OF- SHARED CONCERN AND
PRIORITY FOR ME AND FOR OTHER
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AND- SENATOR GROW AT THAT AS
WELL I HAVE HAVE RAISED THIS
ISSUE AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE- IT'S A IT'S AN ISUE
THAT I HOPE MY RECORD SHOWS. I
CARE ABOUT HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS MORE STEPS NEED
TO BE TAKEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
RESULT YET. BUT WE KNOW THAT
WITH M. C. RSA THAT I WORKED ON
WITH. KERR JONES SAWYER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY-
SOMETHING MEMBER WHAT IF THE
MEMBER COOLEY AND PROP SIXTY
FOUR- AFTER THAT WE CREATED A
REGULATORY REGIME AROUND
MEDICAL CANNABIS AND ADULT USE
CANNABIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE CONTACT. OF
THE ARRANGEMENT IS. COME OUT OF
THE SHADOWS INTO THE LIGHT. BE
A LEGAL BUSINESS FOLLOWING ALL
THE RULES FOLLOW TH REGULATORY
REGIME AND YOU CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT YOU CAN
CREATE GOOD JOBS AND PAY YOUR
TAXES. AND HAVE A THRIVING
BUSINESS. BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD
THAT SHIFT YET- FROM THE
ILLICIT MARKET PLACE TO THE
LEGAL REGULATED MARKETPLACE. SO
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT IT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS IT. AND THE ONE
THING YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE IT WE NEED TO STOP
THE OPERATIONS THAT'S WHAT'S
KEY IT UNDERMINES THE LEGAL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
MIGHTILY TO COMPLY TO FOLLOW
ALL THE RULES TO PAY THEIR
TAXES TO DO IT RIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR THEIR PRODUCT
IS TESTED IN A STAYS AWAY FROM
KIDS AND THAT THERE ARE- AM
HONORING THE ENVIRONMENT. SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
THEY GET SHUT DOWN EXACTLY HOW
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE IT. I'D
LIKE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE OF THE
DOJ LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU FROM
SEVEN MEMBER LACKEY WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. I DO WANT TO AVOID.
ANY ACNE WAR ON DRUGS. I DON'T
WANT TO GO THE OVER
CRIMINALIZATION ROUTE. BUT I DO
WANT THE ILLICIT MARKET. TO IT
TO GO AWAY AND TO HAVE ONE
MARKET PLACE I REGULATED
REGULATED SAFE MARKET PLACE
THAT HONORS OUR- OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR CHILDREN. AND
PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO THE EXTENT
THERE IS ADDITIONAL CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY OCCURRING ABOVE
BESIDES ACTUAL ILLICIT-
OPERATIONS THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. IN A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING YEAH I THINK WHEN
YOU WE SPOKE YOU MENTIONED EVEN
MURDER- YOU KNOW IF THERE NEEDS
TO BE- ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT.
WE HAVE TOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAPPENS AND I KNOW ALSO IN
RURAL AREAS LIKE LIKE YOURS.
YOU TALK ABOUT RESOURCES AND
STAFFING NEED FOR SUPPORT AFTER
DOJ CAN CAN COME IN I HOPE AND
BELIEVE JOINT TASK FORCE IS
WORKING TOGETHER MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS. THE SIZE
SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE ACTUAL
PROBLEM. SO HI THIS IS AN AREA
WHERE I WANT TO GET FULLY
BRIEFED UP BY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE BUT AN AREA OF CONCERN
AS A LEGISLATOR. AND AREA THAT
I'D LIKE TO WORK ON WITH YOU.
THE YOU. FOR THAT CAN TO IT AND
I'D LOVE TO TAKE A TOUR YOU CAN
SEE FIRSTHAND. I GUESS. MY NEXT
QUESTION IS WE ALL KNOW THERE'S
CONCERNS WITH THE BACKLOG IN
THE APPS SYSTEM. WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM FOR
YEARS I'VE YET TO SEE ANY REAL
PROGRESS WHAT WE DO TO PROCESS
THE BACKLOG AND ENSURE RE
REMOVING FIREARMS FROM
PROHIBITED PERSONS. THAT'S
ANOTHER AREA OF A SHARED.
PRIORITY AND CONCERN AND EVERY
THAT THAT I'VE WORKED ON AND
LEGISLATURE RIGHT WHEN I FIRST
CAME IN TWENTY TWELVE TO HELP
SUPPORT A I BUDGET ALLOCATION
TO- HELP REDUCE THE APPS LIST.
AND I WON'T YOU WANT TO REDUCE
THE LAST AS FAST AS WE CAN AS
AS ACCURATELY AND THOROUGHLY AS
WE CAN AND KEEP THE NUMBERS AS
LOW AS POSSIBLE. AND THE ONE
THING I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
ABOUT THE APPS LIST IS THAT IT
THE DYNAMIC AS YOU REMOVED
PEOPLE FROM THE LIST MORE COME
ON ABOUT TEN THOUSAND NEW-
ADDITION TO THE LISTING FOR
EVERY YEAR AND ABOUT ON AVERAGE
TEN THOUSAND ARE REMOVED SO
THERE IS PROGRESS BEING MADE IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE BEING- MORE
ACTIVE CASES COME IN. AND WHEN
I WAS ELECTED IN TWENTY TWELVE
THAT BUDGET ALLOCATION DID LEAD
TO THE BACKLOG AT THAT TIME
BEING ARE TOTALLY ADDRESSED
OVER THREE YEARS BUT MORE HAVE
COME IN AND JUST TO CHALLENGES
REALLY AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT CAN
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE ONE IS-
A TECHNOLOGICAL PLATFORM.
THAT'S COUNTY AND NOT AS
MODERNIZE AND AS AS HELPFUL AS
POSSIBLE- IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
CAN DO KERRY'S AND I AND HAVE
ACCURATE DATA THAT IS UP TO
DATE THAT CAN BE HELPFUL IN
LEADING TO WHAT IS DONE AS YOU
KNOW ON THE GROUND WHICH IS
ACTUALLY- AGENTS KNOCKING ON
SOMEONE'S DOOR- AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO HAS- A WEAPONS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE UNDER THE LAW.
THE SECOND ISSUE IS WE HAVE
ABOUT A 30% VACANCY RATE IN.
THAT WORK FORCE A SPECIAL
AGENTS WHO DO THE WORK. AND SO
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THOSE ATTRACTION AND
RETENTION ISSUES. I HAVE. TOP
NOTCH HIGH QUALITY SPECIAL
AGENTS THAT CAN DO THE JOB.
EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY- AND
THEN I'M OPEN TO OTHER IDEAS
FOR HOW WE CAN WORK ON IT
TOGETHER. I ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THOUGHT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT WOULD BE TO HAVE.
PERHAPS A LEGISLATIVE DOJ
WORKING GROUP. HOWEVER WE WORK
ON THIS TOGETHER WE CAN GIVE
UPDATES ON WHAT WE'RE DOING WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT I HAVE THE HONOR OF BEING
CONFIRMED. AND WE CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON HOW TO
OVERCOME THOSE OBSTACLES. SO MY
HOPE IS THAT IS YOUR HELP AND
I'M I'M I PARK AT THE PRIORITY
FOR ME. AND I'M COMMITTED TO
GETTING THE APPS WEST. AT THE
LOWEST. LEVEL POSSIBLE. JUST A
FOLLOW UP TO THAT I READ. NINE
COUNTIES AND I'VE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM MY COUNTY
SHERIFF'S. THAT IN THE PAST THE
DOJ HAS- COME INTO THOSE LOCAL
COUNTIES. SPECIFICALLY TO- DO
WHAT THEY CALL BLOCKING TALKS
WITH THE- PEOPLE YOU KNOW FOR.
PERSONS ON THE OUTPUT LIST. I
JUST WAS WONDERING- HOW YOU A
BETTER COMMUNICATION IN THE
FORT BUT THE DOJ AND THE LOCAL
SHERIFFS AND OF THOSE
DEPARTMENTS THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR IS THAT THEY DON'T
FIND OUT AFTER THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE BEEN IN THEIR AREA-
AGENTS HAVE COME IN WITHOUT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE SELF I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR BETTER
COMMUNICATION FOR OUR LOCAL.
ELECTED AND I JUST I HAVE ONE
MORE ONE MORE QUESTION. WITH
THE MESSAGE VIOLENCE AND HATE
CRIMES ON THE RISE THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SCARED. IN THE RURAL DISTRICTS
LIKE MINE ON CHRISTMAS SERVICE
FIRST RESPONDERS AND PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. IN MANY PORTIONS
OF MY DISTRICT IN THE STATE
RESPONSE TIMES ARE. FOR THE
NEAR SHORE AFTER DEPUTY
COMMITTEE UP TO AN HOUR.
ADDITIONALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUDGETS. FIND KEY AVENUES FOR
JUSTICE AN ESSENTIAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR VICTIMS SUCH
AS SEXUAL ASSAULT MEDICAL
FORENSIC EXAMS. HOW DO YOU
BALANCE THE NEED FOR REFORM
WHICH WILL AGREE. BUT ALSO THE
NEED FOR COMMUNITY PROTECTION.
THANK YOU LET ME LET ME ANSWER
YOUR FIRST QUESTION FIRST.
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT ONE. I
THINK WE SPOKE YESTERDAY AND
SINCE THEN I LOOKED INTO THE
ISSUE OF COMMUNICATION WHEN THE
APPS A SPECIAL AGENTS ARE. ARE
DOING NOTHING TAX OR- YOU KNOW
FLUCTUATING- A SEIZURE OF GUNS
FROM SOMEONE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
THEM. THE INTENT AND THAT THE
PROTOCOL IS TO HAVE
COMMUNICATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- SOMETIMES
OVERLAPPING LAW ENFORCEMENT
LIKE A POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE SHERIFF MIGHT HAVE SOME
OVERLAPPING JURISDICTION. AND
SO MAYBE ONE OF THEM COULD BE
COMMUNICATED TO BUT NOT THE
OTHER I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE. THE SHARES THAT
JURISDICTION. IS AWARE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING
WORKIG TOGETHER COLLABORATING.
COMMUNICATING AS THE SECOND
QUESTION. THE. MY BELIEF IS
THAT CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE THAT REFORM
SMART REFORM MAKES US SAFER IN
ADDITION TO MAKING US MORE JUST
AND MORE FAIR. AND SO. THAT
BROUGHT IN THIRTY TWO YEAR YOUR
QUESTION IS WE NEED TAX UPLIFT
ABOUT- FAIRNESS AND JUSTICE.
AND WHILE WE ALSO EMPHASIZE
SAFETY AND I THINK WE CAN AND
ARE ABLE TO GET BOTH OF THOSE
DONE SO IN OUR CONVERSATIONS-
THAT ISSUES ARE NUANCED AND IF
IT'S A CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
IDEA BEING PROPOSED AND-
SOMEONE SAYS WELL LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACTS ON COMMUNITY
SAFETY THAT'S APPROPRIATE WE
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THAT.
AND THERE SHOULD BE GOOD GOOD
RESPONSES TO HAVE IT ALSO MAKES
A OUR COMMUNITY SAFE- AND AT
THE CORE. I BELIEVE IT TOUGH TO
MUCH OF THIS IS THE NEED TO
BUILD GREATER COMMUNITY FAST-
BUTTON ALONG FOR SMITH AND OUR
COMMUNITY AND MY VIEW IS THAT-
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL.
ARE INVALUABLE PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THE VAST MAJORITY
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. WANTS TO
BUILD AND MAINTAIN THAT TRUST I
JUST TALKED ABOUT. AND ALSO ARE
DESERVING OF SUPPORT. AND
TRAINING- FOR HOW TO IMPLEMENT.
REFORM THAT KEEPS THEM SAFE
KEEP THE COMMUNITY SAFE IT ALSO
MAKES US. MORE JUST MORE FAIR
THE COMMUNITY AND A SOCIETY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE AS
FAR HE HAD IN THIS ROCKY. WELL
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS HAVE FOR
BEING HERE AND- IT'S AN HONOR
IS YOUR COLLEAGUE TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION AND VOTE ON YOUR
CONFIRMATION TODAY SO THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME YOU'VE SPENT
WORKING ON. HEARING FOR THIS
AND HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
WITH THAT. I WANT TO START WITH
REPRODUCTIVE CHOICE. AND THE
AG'S OFFICE PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN ENSURING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA. GENERALLY BY
OVERSEEING MERGERS OF HOSPITALS.
IN MANY PARTS OF THE STATE
WE'RE SEEING MERGERS WITH
CATHOLIC HOSPITALS THAT PREVENT
SAYS TOO MANY REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES. I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO DISCUSS YOUR POSITION ON
THESE MURDERS THAT WOULD DENY
WOMEN ACCESS TO TUBAL LIGATION
TNCS ABORTIONS AND OTHER
SERVICES. AND WE DO NOT A
TRANCE CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO
THE CARE THEY NEED TO
TRANSITION WITH DIGNITY I WHAT
YOU WOULD DO TO PREVENT. THAT
THE DENIAL OF BACK HERE. THANK
YOU THAT ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- BACK IN
FORCE AND SUPPORT THE EXISTING
LINE CALIFORNIA- THAT ENHANCE
THAT HAS BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM WE HAVE
SOME OF THE STRONGEST LAWS IN
THE NATION AND SO THE EIGHTIES
WRONG GENERALLY IS TO- DEFEND
AND ENFORCE OUR LAWS I ONE OF
THAT SPECIFIC ROLES THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOUSE IS TO-
REVIEW AND APPROVE OR NOT OR
NOT APPROVE- CONSOLIDATIONS OF
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS SO IT'S
LIMITED AMOUNT PASSED WITH AT
THE MOMENT OF THE BILLS IN THE
PAST THAT WE'RE AWARE OF THAT
HAVE SOUGHT TO EXPAND AT A
THIRTY BUT NOW IT'S FOR
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS. AND IF
THEY FOR EXAMPLE A RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATED HOSPITAL. DOES NOT
PROVIDE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. YEAH TO MERGE. WITH AN
HOSPITAL THAT DOES. IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE ATTORNEY- DO
A REVIEW AND I AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE THAT REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE- SERVICES CONTINUE
TO BE PROVIDED. THAT THAT'S
WHAT THE AG'S OFFICE IN THE
PAST AND COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT GOING FORWARD.
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR ME AND I
WILL BE CHAMPION FOR. THANK YOU
SO ONE FOLLOW UP THAT I JUST
YOU KNOW I'M I'M YOUR COLLEAGUE
HERE AND WORK WITH YOU AND I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE RECORD. ON
REPRODUCTIVE CARE PROTECTING
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU HAVE ANY
ROLE IN THIS JOB AND SO I JUST
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU COMMIT TO
DEFENDING. SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE- AND
SPECIFICALLY ABORTION SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA. IN YOUR ROLE AS
AG. YES I MEAN THAT WE HAVE AS
I MENTIONED WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST LOSS IN SUPPORT OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE-
ABORTION ACCESS. I WILL FIGHT
IN DEFENDING CHAMPION THOSE
LAWS THANK YOU- I WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MOVING ON TO
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION- OF OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH STATE
WHO TALK ABOUT THE APPS LESS I
THINK IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE WE PASS A LOT OF US. IN
THIS BODY AND ENFORCEMENT OF
THEM IS REALLY CRITICAL AND NOW
YOU WILL HAVE A ROLE TO ENFORCE
THEM AND I THINK THE APPS LIST
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
AND I WON'T ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS
ADDRESS BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE SPENT A LOT
OF MONEY. THE GOVERNMENT TRYING
TO CLEAR THAT OBSOLESCENCE AND
I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY WE FAIL TO DO IT
AND I THINK WE NEED TO USE NEW
TECHNIQUES AND I COMMEND OUR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
WHO IS THOUGHT ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BETTER COORDINATE WITH LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND I JUST HOPE
THAT WE WILL DO THE WORK YOU
TALKED ABOUT- AND BEING
CREATIVE TO ENSURE WE'RE TAKING
THOSE GUNS AWAY FROM
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WHO
SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM AND POSE A
RISK- THE- IN YOUR LETTER YOU
ADDRESSED. ONE ISSUE THAT MR
KING IS CURRENTLY TAKING UP IN
THIS BODY WHICH IS THE CURRENT
REFUSAL OF OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY DATA
FOR UC DAVIS TO DO THE WORK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS AND
ASK THEM TO DO. TO REALLY DO
THE RESEARCH THAT OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED TO DO ON
OUR GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION
POLICIES AND HOW THEY WORK AND
I THINK DATA AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE AND
HOW IT'S EXCEEDING IS SO
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY IN SUCH A
CONTROVERSIAL SPACE AS GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION SO I KNOW
YOU DISCUSSED IT- SHORTLY IN
YOUR LETTER BUT I JUST WANTED
YOU TO SPEAK ABOUT YOUR
DEDICATION. OR YOUR WILLINGNESS.
TO REALLY BE A PARTNER IN THAT
RESEARCH. I WANT TO BE THE
STRONGEST PASSED NOT RESEARCH
THE RESEARCH IS CRITICAL WE ALL
TALK ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED
POLICY DATA DRIVEN POLICY YOU
NEED TO HAVE THE DATA AND THE
EVIDENCE THE DRIVE THAT POLICY
AND YOU NEED THE RESEARCHERS
TECH TO PROVIDE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION THAT INPUT SO MY
GOAL WOULD BE TO PROVIDE ALL
DATA THAT IS LEGALLY
PERMISSIBLE TO BE PROVIDED FOR
RESEARCHERS TO RESEARCHERS
TODAY SO THEY CAN DO THEIR WORK
WORK THEIR MAGIC AND BE THE
PARTNERS IN DRIVING GOOD POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA THEY CAN BE.
THANK YOU I'M SO MOVING ON TO
THE ENVIRONMENT I KNOW. WE'RE
BOTH PARENTS AND I KNOW WE'RE
BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL WARRIORS AND
I THINK THAT OUR KIDS ARE A
HUGE PART OF WHY. WE CARE SO
DEEPLY ABOUT- OUR FUTURE AND
CLIMATE CHANGE ON THIS PLANET
BEING HABITABLE- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION THAT
YOU'VE SHOWN ALREADY TO THAT
ISSUE AND I. I KNOW YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO SHOW- I WANTED TO
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE- YOU
DISCUSSED IN YOUR LETTER. THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT. IS YOU KNOW I
PRACTICED ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
FOR. AND FOR A FEW YEARS AND-
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
AGAIN WE CAN PASS ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS WE WANT IN
THIS BODY BUT IF ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT EQUITABLE THAN OUR LAWS
WILL BE EQUITABLE. AND I THINK
THAT IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT
WE ENSURE THAT THE RESOURCES OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
ARE USED TO ENSURE THAT THOSE.
ENTITIES THAT ARE HARMING OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE HELD TO
ACCOUNT. AND I THINK THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT IS ANALYZING. THE
WAYS THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
THOSE LAWYERS WERE INCREDIBLE
LAWYERS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT ENFORCE OUR BERMAN ALLIES.
WILL YOU ANALYZE HOW THAT'S
BEING USED AND SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ARE BEING USED TO. TO
GO AFTER THOSE THAT ARE HARMING
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
HAVE SUFFERED SO FOR SO LONG
WITH A HEALTHY CONDITION. IN
SHORT YES. THE A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT NAMES FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SOME SAY THE
TOP TAX SOME SAY THAT CHIEF
OPERATION OFFICER SOME SAY THE
CHIEF LAW OFFICER. I CALLED THE
PEOPLE'S ATTORNEY THE PERSON
WITH A CHAMPION FOR THE
VOICELESS THE VULNERABLE THE
OVERLOOKED THE CAST ASIDE. AND
SEE THEM AND FIGHT FOR THEM
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE BEING
HURT BY THOSE WHO ARE OVER
REACHING THEIR POWER ABUSING
THEIR POWER THAT'S THE JOB. IN
THE HIGH LEVEL THAT'S THE JOB
DESCRIPTION AND WHEN IT COMES
TO USING LIMITED RESOURCES WE
NEED TO HELP THOSE WHO NEED IT
MOST FIRST SO THAT IS OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
IS A VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT IS THOSE WHO ARE SUFFERING
AT THE INTERSECTION OF
POLLUTION AND POVERTY OFTEN.
BUTTON BROWN COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO YES.
THANK YOU. I'M MOVING ON TO A
TOPIC I KNOW YOUR PASSION ABOUT
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COLONEL JUSTICE REFORM. HAVE
YOU IN YOUR LETTER DISCUSSED.
RENEWING TRUST. AND THAT BEING
A BIG PART OF THE WORK WE HAVE
AHEAD OF US BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND I THINK IT WAS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT FOCUS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- UNDER
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH SIX THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
INVESTIGATING. OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS OF UNARMED CIVILIANS
BUT THAT NARROW. RIGHT IN THAT
IT'S ONLY UNARMED CIVILIANS-
AND THERE ADDITIONAL INSTANCES
WHERE. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
NEEDED TO STEP IN IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FAITH IN
THE PROCESS- AND- YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
HESITANT TO DO THAT THESE ARE
CONTROVERSIAL CASES. BUT THIS
IS WHERE TRUST CAN BE BROKEN IF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST OR SOME
OTHER REASON THAT THERE WOULD
BE AN APPROPRIATE AUTHORITY AND
THEY ASK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE STEP AND- YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THAT. OFFICE STEP
IN AND DO WHAT IS NEEDED IN THE
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE WE REBUILD
TRUST AND SO I WANTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU WHAT WHAT YOUR
POSITION IS ON- OTHER
SITUATIONS WHERE DE ASKING
TOURNEY GENERAL THE STEP IN
WHERE THERE'S BEEN- AN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING BUT MAYBE THE
INDIVIDUALS FIRST. FOR EXAMPLE
ARMED. THANK YOU. THE AGAIN AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ARE
ABSOLUTELY INVALUABLE PARTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY I BELIEVE MOST
THE VAST MAJORITY WANT TO BUILD
AND MAINTAIN THE TRUST THAT I
TALK ABOUT I WANT IMPORTANT
PART OF TRUST AS POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T HAVE TRUST WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO NEED OTHER
THINGS I CAN THINK ANY
INVESTMENTS- SERVICE TRAINING
SUPPORT- THE ADDRESS IMPLICIT
AND EXPLICIT BIAS DE ESCALATION
COMMUNITY POLICING. AND
IDENTIFY INVESTIGATE HATE
CRIMES. AND PLEASE KINDLY WITH
THE SPEC OPS IN MARKETING IS
AWFULLY CRITICAL- THE MESSAGE
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY WHO WORKED ON THIS BILL
IN MULTIPLE VERSIONS FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS I WAS PROUD TO
WORK WITH HIM AND BE A CO
AUTHOR OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX IT
IS ONE OF. THE MOST IMPORTANT-
PRIORITIES AND THINGS THE NEXT
DAY HE WILL DO WHICH IS STAND
UP. THE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING. DIVISION IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. IT'S
SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WE NEED
TO GET IT RIGHT. IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE ARE THESE INVESTIGATIONS
NEED TO BE DONE COMPREHENSIVELY
AND THOROUGHLY AND ACCURATELY-
WITH WITH THE UTMOST INTEGRITY
TO EARN THE TRUST THAT I
MENTIONED WE DON'T HAVE INTO
MANY COMMUNITIES. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE GENERALLY HAS
NOT DONE A LARGE NUMBER OF
THESE INVESTIGATIONS EACH YEAR
SO IT'S IN SOME WAYS A- A
LARGER- RESPONSIBILITY THAN
THEY'VE EVER HAD- WE EXPECT
BASED ON HISTORICAL DATA THAT
ABOUT. THAT THERE WILL BE ABOUT
FORTY QUALIFYING OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS EACH YEAR. A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH SIX
AND THOSE ARE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS. THAT RESULT IN THE
DEATH OF AN UNARMED CALIFORNIA.
I'M COMMITTED TO GETTING THAT
RIGHT IF I HAVE THE HONOR
PRIVILEGE OF BEING THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL I GETTING THE
RIGHT PERSON NON PLACE. GETTING
THE RIGHT INFRASTRUCTURE
GETTING THE RIGHT. GIVEN THE
ABILITY TO DO TO TRANSPORT
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA GET ON
THE SCENE. IN SHORT NOTICE
FLECKED OF THAT STORE THE
EVIDENCE PUT TOGETHER A CASE
EVALUATED MAKE A CHARGING
DECISION THE CHARGING DECISION
IS TO CHARGE. MOVED TO TRIAL.
AND PERON- YOU KNOW A STRONG
CASE OF JUSTICE GO WITH A LOT
OF FACTS TAKE YOU. SO THAT'S MY
FOCUS AND THAT'S MY PRIORITY I
SHOULD I HAVE THE HONOR OF
BEING CONFIRMED- ARE THERE
OTHER TIMES WHEN- ANNOUNCER BOB
SHOOTING REQUIRES INVESTIGATION
POTENTIALLY BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. YES THERE ARE- THERE
ARE COMPLICATIONS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TAKES
NOW WHEN A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR EXAMPLE A FAMILY MEMBER OR
A MEMBER OF THE OFFICE IS
EITHER A VICTIM OR A DEFENDANT
IN THE CASE SAID THOSE ARE SORT
OF CLEAR CASES OF CONFLICT AND
IT TURNED OUT HAS TAKEN ON
TAKING THOSE ON HIS OTHER CASES
WHERE SOMEONE. OR A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- IT'S MAYBE NOT A FORM
OFFICIAL CONFLICT BUT- THAT
COULD BE THE PARENTS OF A
CONFLICT AND SO THEY THINK IT'S
BEST NOT TO TAKE THE CASE OR
MAYBE THEY DECIDE NOT TO CHARGE.
THAT THE FAMILIES OF THE PERSON
WHOSE LIFE WAS LOST. IN THOSE
INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY DESERVE
JUSTICE AND THEY DESERVE
SOMEONE TO LOOK AT THE CASE.
WHO AND WITH WHAT RESOURCES
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO TALK ABOUT
IT COULD BE IN AND OUTSIDE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR IT COULD
BE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE BUT AGAIN- IF I AM
RETURNING GENERAL AND I HAVE
THE HONOR OF A TO BE CONFIRMED
MY COMMITMENT. IS TO. BE
ACCURATE AND COMPREHENSIVE AND
THOROUGH. AND GET IT RIGHT FOR
EVERY OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
THAT WE DO THAT'S WHAT I WE GO
TO THE FAMILY. OF THE LOVE ONE
LAST. THE PERSON UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS ASKING THE
AG TO DO THESE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU- THE NEXT TOPIC IS A-
TIMELY ONE JUST TODAY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY CHARGED OFFICER.
FOR MANSLAUGHTER IN THE
SHOOTING AND THE STAR BALATA.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THAT
OFFICER WENT ON TO SHOOT
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL JUSTICE
ABOUT A MONTH AGO IN OUR
COMMUNITY AFTER HE STAYED ON
THE JOB. AFTER COMMITTING WHAT.
IS KNOWLEDGE SEVEN
MANSLAUGHTER- AND I THINK THAT.
THIS BODY LAST YEAR STARTED THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT
DECERTIFICATION AND WHAT
OFFICES ARE APPROPRIATE TO
CARRY THE BATCH AND CONTINUE TO
CARRY THE BADGE AFTER CERTAIN
ACTIONS AND I THINK IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
AND ONE THAT IS ON GOING IS YOU
KNOW IN THIS BODY. I'M
CURRENTLY THE PROPOSALS ON THE
TABLE OR DIFFERENCE WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS OF WHAT
DECERTIFICATION WILL LOOK LIKE-
SB TWO PROPOSES THAT THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS WOULD
SIT IN POST. AND I THINK THAT'S-
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT THAT
I HAVE FOR YOU AND IT'S AN OPEN
QUESTION FOR ME IS THAT MY GUT
TELLS ME THE BEST PLACE FOR
THAT PROCESS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS NOT A POLICE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING- AND I
JUST WONDERED WHAT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT IS AND
WHETHER YOU WOULD BE A PARTNER
IN HAVING THAT CONVERSATION
ABOUT WEIRD BASS THE
DECERTIFICATION PROCESS SHOULD
SET. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION THE- CONTACT WITH THE
CERTIFICATION IS ONE I'VE- AS A
LEGISLATOR I'VE BEEN DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN- CO AUTHOR OF SB.
TWO CALIFORNIA TAX OFTEN ABOUT
HOW WE LEAD WERE FIRST REVOLT-
NOT WITH WHEN IT COMES TO
DECERTIFICATION WITH FORTY FIVE
OTHER STATES ALREADY HAVE DONE
THIS SO THIS IS NOT A YOU
SHOULD NOT BE A CONTROVERSIAL-
CONCEPT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- HOW WE DO IT IS
IMPORTANT- DUE PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT- WHO MAKES THE
DECISION IS IMPORTANT. SO I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT THE
DECERTIFICATION. AT THIS TIME I
DON'T HAVE A FIRM OPINION ABOUT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT BODIES
THAT COULD BE JUNE THE
DECERTIFICATION OF COURSE
YOU'VE MENTIONED TO POST IN THE
OJ I'D LIKE TO GIVE THAT SOME
THOUGHT IF- IF POSSIBLE MAYBE
CONSULT WITH SOME OF THE-
EXPERT IN DOJ ON THIS ISSUE
JUST TO PROVIDE AN OPINION ON
THAT BUT- I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT WHERE IT RESTS.AND
WE'RE RESIDES BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WE ALL BELIEVE THAT SOMEONE WHO
HAS COMMITTED EGREGIOUS
MISCONDUCT SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO BE FIRED FROM A JOB AND THEN
POP UP SOMEWHERE ELSE AND HER
COMMUNITIES IN THAT NEW PLACE-
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE TRUST IN IN
THAT SYSTEM THAT IS BEING DONE
RIGHT. AND ACCURATELY AND
FAIRLY SO- I LIKE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT AFTER AFTER
FURTHER REFLECTION IF THAT'S
OKAY YES OF COURSE THANK YOU
AND ONE LAST QUESTION. AND I'LL
TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE- SO
ONE OF THE THINGS. YOU I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF SITTING ON THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE WITH.
CHRISTINE SHARE- AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT OFTEN. I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES WHO I BELIEVE IS
GOING NEXT- OFTEN REFLECTS ON
IN COMMITTEE. IS THAT THE
VICTIMS ARE OFTEN MISSING FROM
OUR CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND YOU
ACTUALLY MENTIONED THIS EARLIER
THAT. A LOT OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM CAN BENEFIT
VICTIMS THE VICTIMS- ARE A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION I KNOW IN
YOUR LETTER YOU SPOKE ABOUT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND I
BELIEVE THEY WERE SORT OF
JUSTICE OFTEN IS SOMETHING THE
VICTIMS- YOU KNOW ARE PART OF
IN SOME OF THESE MOVES IN A LOT
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CAN
BE A VICTIM CENTERED. BUT I
JUST THINK THAT IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
KEEP THEM. IN THE CONVERSATION
AND CENTERED IN THE WORK WE DO
AS WE DO WORK ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM AND SO I WAS
WANTED TO HEAR BRIEFLY FROM YOU
HOW YOU IS. OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL KEEP VICTIMS IN THE
CENTER OF THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM. ASK THE QUESTION WHO
COMMITTED THE CRIME OF THE
CRIMES COMMITTED WHO COMMITTED
IT WHAT WE COULD DO ABOUT
PERSONAL PASSION- WHATEVER
TRIBUTE OF SYSTEM THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR THE MOST
PART A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AFTER A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT QUESTION THAT IS
VICTIM CENTERED. THAT'S WHO'S
THE VICTIM WHAT DO THEY NEED TO
HEAL AND HOW WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT- THAT'S SUPER IMPORTANT TO
ME THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE- TO
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMERS TO
MAKE SURE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
VICTIM IMPACT STATEMENT THAT
THAT HAPPENED WITH THE VOICE OF
A VICTIM CAN COME INTO THE TO
THE- PROCESS. IN SENTENCING IT
NEEDS TO BE MORE CENTER THAN
NOT- AND ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
BEEN TALKING I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT SHOULD I HAVE DONE
APPROVED TO BEING CONFIRMED IS
HAVING A MORE ROBUST
CENTRALIZED VICTIMS SERVICES
COMPONENT THAT THE DOJ IS A
PART OF PERHAPS WITH OTHER
PARTS OF THE OF THE STATE OKAY
THAT'S MORE ROBUST AND PROVIDES
THEM GREATER VOICE AND GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORTING
HAILING. FROM BEGINNING TO THE
END OF THE PROCESS NOT JUST
WHEN IT'S TIME TO SENSE. THANK
YOU THAT'S THE QUESTION I HAVE
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPENNESS HERE TODAY BUT
ALSO OVER THE YEARS THAT WE'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER AND I KNOW. AND THAT
GOING FORWARD AS- YOU KNOW IF
THIS BODY CONFIRMS YOU AND THE
SENATE- THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE A COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP ON MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE- AND THE VALUES
THAT WE SHARE I THINK IT WAS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
HISTORICALLY HAVE I HAVE MR
LACKEY THAN MISTER CHALLENGES
WITH. SLASH WELL YOU I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY USER FEEDBACK IS
IT JUST ME. THIS YEAR. I LIKE
TO THINK THAT YOU'RE FORGIVEN
FOR NOT THE CHAIR BUT- THE
LEADER OF. THE STATE ASSEMBLY
FOR ALLOWING ME TO- BE PART OF
THIS PROCESS IT'S CLEARLY AN
HONOR. AND THERE THERE ARE A
FEW LEGISLATORS THAT- HAVE LESS
IN COMMON WITH ME THAN THE ONE
I'M SPEAKING TO NOW AS FAR AS
POLITICALLY GOES. BUT I HAVE TO
SAY THAT YOU'RE ALSO A PERSON
THAT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
COLLEGIAL. IN THE WAY THAT- YOU
DISAGREE AND THAT IS. THAT'S A
SOUGHT AFTER GIFT IN MY OPINION
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW
MUCH OF APPRECIATED. BEING ABLE
TO WORK WITH YOU EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S ONLY BEEN A FEW THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON. AND- IT TRULY IS
AN HONOR. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY. JUST SOME. REALLY QUICK
AND COGENT REMARKS FROM ON SOME
VERY VERY HEARTFELT. SENTIMENTS
THAT I HAVE TOWARDS POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY. I BELIEVE IT'S
HURTFUL AND UNFAIR TO DEFINE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSION
THROUGH MISCONDUCT OF A FEW.
AND INSTEAD I BELIEVE THAT WE
MUST LEARN FROM THAT MISCONDUCT
AND MUST REDEFINE. THE
PROFESSION TO REASONABLE
MEASURES. AND I'M HOPING THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN ARRIVING AT
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE- EXCLUSION
LEADS TO WITNESS AN INCLUSION
LEADS TO STRENGTH AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO MAKE THOSE REMARKS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THEY'RE
VERY VERY. IMPORTANT TO THE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR STATE
HERE. AND I'D LIKE TO BEGIN. BY
FOLLOWING UP WITH THE- SOME OF
THE REMARKS OF THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY EXPRESSED ABOUT
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT THOSE OF THIS ISSUE BUT
IT IS BECOMING. AN ALARMING
PROBLEM I MADE A VERY VERY.
IT'S NOT ONLY SOCIALLY A
PROBLEM IT'S BECOME AN
ECONOMICALLY A BIG BIG PROBLEM
AND AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD NOT BE- GETTING PROFITS
THROUGH THIS- THIS ISSUE SO. A
RECENT FORBES ARTICLE SUGGESTED
THE CALIFORNIANS- CALIFORNIA IS
A LIST OF CANNABIS MARKET
PLACES ANYWHERE FROM TWICE TO
THREE TIMES AS BIG AS THE LEGAL
MARKET. AND AS WE SAW WITH THE
PREVIOUS ATTORNEY GENERAL THERE
WAS A LOT OF FINGER POINTING.
AS TO WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IT
WAS. TO GO AFTER THE ILLICIT
GROWERS ANALYSTS AT RETAILERS
THE STATE WOULD SHIFT THE
AUTHORITY TO LOCALS IN THE
LOCALS WOULD SHIP THE AUTHORITY
TO THE STATE. AND SO AS THE
STATE. I WOULD SAY TOP. LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL BUT YOU
LIKE ATTORNEY BETTER SO LET
THAT- HOW YOU DIRECT YOUR
RESOURCES TOWARD SHUTTING DOWN
THE ILLICIT MARKET AND AGAIN. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT I'M NOT
ADVOCATING UNIVERSITY ASPECT. I
WANT TO GO AFTER THE MONEY. AND
THE MONEY IS HOW YOU HAVE
IMPACT ON THIS PROBLEM. YES
THANK YOU SOME NEVER LACKING
FOR LET ME JUST FIRST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT TO THE VERY
BEGINNING- I'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH CARTER BILLS TOGETHER
WE'VE- ASKED WE WORK ON THE M.
C. RSA A HUGE. IMPACT AND MINE-
VIEW OF ALONG WITH A CHAIR
JONES SAWYER AND OTHERS-
BREAKTHROUGH ON AN ISSUE THAT
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING TO OVERCOME. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WAY HE
WAS CONDUCTING YOURSELF WITH ME
WE'VE HAD OUR DISAGREEMENTS BUT
RESPECTFUL ONES AND I'VE I'VE
LEARNED FROM MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU. AND IT'S MADE ME I
HOPE- A BETTER MORE THOUGHTFUL
LEADER SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK. YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU-
THE LIST MARKET PLACE. ME
ATTENTION AND TO ADDRESS IT
WILL BE RESOURCES. HI I SHARE
YOUR VIEW OF NOT MAKING THE
RESPONSE ONE THAT LEADS TO- YOU
KNOW. PEOPLE IN CUSTODY YOU
KNOW IN CRIMINAL CUSTODY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS
THAT- BUT I KNOW THAT THAT WE
DO NEED TO GET AS YOU SAY TO
THE MONEY WE NEED TO END THE
OPERATIONS. I DON'T KNOW- WHAT
THE INTRODUCTION OF WHAT THAT
ACTION WHAT THE VARIATION MENU
OF OPTIONS ARE AND WHICH ONE IS
BEST BUT THAT IS SOMETHING I'D
BE COMMITTED TO WORKING ON WITH
YOU. I WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO CERTAINLY WITH THE EXPERT AT
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. BECAUSE
I AGREE WITH YOU WE HAVE.
RESOUNDING AGREEMENT ON THE
PROBLEM- IT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND
IT'S GROWING. AND IT NEEDS
ATTENTION. AND EACH OTHER
PRIORITIES BY WHERE YOU PUT
YOUR RESOURCES THIS NEEDS
RESOURCES. AND IT NEEDS- THE
FINGER POINTING THAT YOU THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT. IT IT TO THE
EXTENT THAT HAPPENING WE SHOULD
BE WORKING TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY- AND A NOT TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AT HAND HOW
POINT FINGERS AT ONE ANOTHER
SO- I'D LIKE TO WORK ON THAT
WITH YOU. AND WITH THAT COMES
THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND I
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
GROWING SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM.
WELL THANK YOU THAT I REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS ISSUE I DON'T SUSPECT YOU
HAVE THE ACT. THE ANSWER AT
THIS POINT. JUST A COMMITMENT
TO WORK ON THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE
IT HAS BECOME A VERY VERY
SERIOUS ONE. NOW FOR THE STICKY
WICKET QUESTION- LAST NOVEMBER
CALIFORNIANS REJECTED
PROPOSITION TWENTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD ELIMINATED CASH BAIL
HOWEVER A FEW MOMENTS I'M SORRY
FEW MONTHS LATER YOU AUTHORED A
BILL THAT WOULD. SET BALLOT
ZERO FOR MORE STE MOST CRIMINAL
OFFENSES AND MANY WOULD SEE
THAT IS DEFYING THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS THE NEW TWENTY SIXTEEN.
VOTERS REJECTED PROP SIXTY TWO
WHICH WOULD HAVE ELIMINATED TE
DEATH PENALTY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEW CEMENT
ISSUED A MORATORIUM ON THE
DEATH PENALTY AND YOU RELEASED
A STATEMENT SAYING YOU APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR'S MORATORIUM ON
THE DEATH PENALTY. AND THAT YOU
BELIEVE THE DEATH PENALTY IS
WRONG FOR CALIFORNIA. ALSO
TWENTY NINETEEN YOU CO AUTHOR
MEASURE THAT WOULD HAVE
ELIMINATED THE DEATH PENALTY.
HOW CALIFORNIA'S TRUST THAT YOU
REALLY RESPECT THEIR VOICES NOT
OVERRIDE THEM THROUGH YOUR
OFFICE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. TOP TWENTY FIVE. WITH
WITH WITH THE VOTERS DECIDED
AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE WILL HAVE
THEIR DIFFERENT VIEWS- TO ME IT
IS ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT IT WAS
NOT A WARM EMBRACE OF THE
STATUS QUO MONEY BAIL SYSTEM. I
DID SEE ONE ADVERTISEMENT I DID
SEE ONE CAMPAIGN COMMUNICATION
I DON'T SEE ONE COMMERCIAL THAT
SAID VOTE FOR PROP TWENTY FIVE
BECAUSE THE EXISTING MONEY BAIL
SYSTEM IS GOOD. THE ONLY
DISCUSSION THE ONLY DEBATE THE
ONLY CAMPAIGN COMMUNICATION.
WAS ABOUT WHAT THE REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM SHOULD BE AND WHETHER
THERE WERE THE PROPOSED FREE
TRIAL REPLACEMENT SYSTEM. IN SB
TEN IN PROP TWENTY FIVE. WAS
APPROPRIATE. THERE WERE SOME
VERY POWERFUL PROGRESSIVE
VOICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE HE
DID NOT THINK IT WAS
APPROPRIATE. THEY HAD ANOTHER
VISION. AND THAT'S WHERE I
THINK THAT'S WHAT I THINK. THAT
I FEEL YOUR PROPOSITION TWENTY
FIVE STANFORD STANDS FOR. THE
PROPOSITION THAT. MONEY BAIL-
IS HOME SAFE UNFAIR UNJUST- AND
WE DON'T YET AGREE ON WHAT THE
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM SHOULD BE.
OTHERS WILL DISAGREE WITHOUT
THAT'S MY VIEW SO YOU'RE SO
IT'S CLEAR I BELIEVE I AM BEING
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
VOTERS- OF CALIFORNIA I HAVE
STATED THEY HAVE THAT BELIEVE
THEY STATED THAT THEY WANT ME
TO GO BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD. AND IDENTIFY A FAIR
SYSTEM TO THE EXISTING STATUS
QUO DUST THE BILL. THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR SKINNER AND I
AUTHORED. HAD MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS- ONE- THAT THAT. WAS
TO REQUIRE THAT THE ABILITY TO
PAY BE CONSIDERED IN SETTING
BAIL THE STATE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE CITED THAT THAT IS THE
LAW OFFICE OF THE STATE SO THAT
COMPONENT IS CONSTITUTIONAL IS
LEGAL WE ALSO HAD A ZERO BAIL
COMPONENT WHICH MIRRORED IS IT
IS ZERO BAIL POLICY OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DURING COATED-
I HAD A COUPON IT SO THAT
THERE'S NO COST FOR- ANY-
CONDITIONS OF. RELEASE AND IT
ALSO HAD A HIGHER REFUND
ABILITY COMPONENT BUT IT
DIDN'T- IT IS OKAY SO IF IT'S A
PROPOSAL- THE LEGISLATURE WILL
DECIDE THOSE ISSUES WERE NOT
VOTED ON AND TOP TWENTY FIVE.
THE MORNING PROPERTY FIVE- SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
SUBJECT TO DEBATE CANNOT
DELIVER TO PROCESS. MAYBE TO
PASS MAYBE IT WON'T- BUT THAT
THE INABILITY TO PAY COMPONENT
IS BECAUSE OF THE JUDICIAL
DECISION A CONFERENCE IS NOW. A
LOT OF THE STATE. DEFINITELY
EXCUSE ME FOR THAT SO THAT THAT
WAS ALL ABOUT- I'M AGAINST THE
DEATH PENALTY THAT'S MY
PERSONAL CHOICE MY PERSONAL
VIEW. I THINK IT'S WRONG FOR
CALIFORNIA. I DID STAND WITH
THE GOVERNOR WHEN HE ISSUE THE
MORE TIME I WAS PROUD TO DO
THAT. I SHOULD THE STATEMENT
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT I DID
ISSUE I DID JOIN WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- LEVINE. IN A PROPOSAL-
TO PUT ON THE BALLOT FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE VOTERS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO-
ABOLISHED THE DEATH PENALTY
THAT- IS CONSISTENT. WITH
SUPPORTING THE VOTERS BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS THE VOTERS TO DECIDE.
AND HAVE. DEFINITELY MY VIEW IS
IN HUMANE. IT DOES NOT DETER-
IT IS BOTH FALLIBLE MEANING
WERE WRONG WHEN YOU SEE THE
DEATH PENALTY SOMETIMES- THE
MOST EGREGIOUS CASES WHEN WE-
HAVE ISSUE THE DENTIST
DEFINITELY TO AN INNOCENT
PERSON. AND A REVERSIBLE YOU
CAN'T BE BOTH. AND IT'S RACIST
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I'M
AGAINST THE DEATH PENALTY I
ALSO AM VERY WELL MY
CONSTITUTINAL DUTIES SHOULD I
BE CONFIRMED AS THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER PEOPLE'S
ATTORNEY- IN THE CONSTITUTION
AND I WILL- DO VOEPEL HONOR AND
MY OBLIGATIONS AND DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND- AS THE
TWENTY GENERAL FUND CONFIRMED
AND- AND BASED ON THAT IDENTIFY
A PROPER PATHWAY FOR REFORM-
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH MY
RESPONSIBILITY MY DUTIES. OKAY
I'M GONNA MOVE ON TO A RAPE KIT.
AND I'VE READ YOUR PROJECT YOUR
SUBMITTED REMARKS REGARDING
RATE CAPS HOWEVER I JUST WANT
TO HAVE FOR THE CLARIFY- YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS DEGREE JUST
PROBLEM TWENTY SEVEN STATES
HAVE COME. COMMITTED TO TESTING
THEIR BACKLOG OF RAPE KITS
ACCORDING TO THE JOYFUL HEART
FOUNDATION WHICH WE HEARD FROM
EARLIER- A RESPECTED NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES TO
END THE BACKLOG- NOT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES THE
TESTING OF ALL S. C. E. CAPS
COLLECTED SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN.
BUT NOT BEFORE. THE RECENT DOJ
AUDIT OF THE RAPE KIT BACKLOG
IDENTIFIED AS SHE INDICATED
JUST UNDER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
UNTESTED KITS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE SIGNIFICANT
UNDERCOUNTS DO THE DO THE
DISMAL RESPONSES SHE INDICATED
A FROM THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES MEDICAL FACILITIES IN
CRIME LABS THAT WERE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO REPORT. WHAT IS
YOUR PLAN AS A THE NEW NEWLY
APPOINTED ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
AND CALIFORNIA'S RAPE KIT
BACKLOG. I'M COMMITTED TO. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. REDUCING
AND REMOTE AND GETTING RID OF
THE STATE'S- AND I SAID I
PROBABLY MAKE IT BACK WHILE
GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT I LIKE
WHAT I MEAN AND- AT THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS I THINK
IS WHAT I SAY. HE STANDS FOR.
AND I'M GONNA CALL BACK- THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO D. O. J.
DOES NOT HAVE A BACKLOG. WHEN
IT COMES TO SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE KITS THERE ARE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT DO. AND I
TALKED TO AND OUR SEXUAL. IT
COMES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT-
DESERVE SUPPORT- THAT THEIR
RIGHTS NEED TO BE VINDICATED-
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH A
HORRIBLE TRAUMA. AND A SECOND
ONE- WHEN THEY'VE GIVEN THE
EXAM AND I'VE TALKED TO SOME
MEMBER DOLLY ABOUT THAT AND
THEN TO SEE THAT KICKED. ON A
SHELF SOMEWHERE GATHERING DUST.
INSTEAD OF BEING PROCESSED ON
THE PATHWAY TO JUSTICE. IT'S
JUST WRONG. I WAS LISTENING TO
THE COMMENTS TODAY I WAS
ACTUALLY TAKING HOMES ABOUT
HAVING A PHYSICAL POTENTIAL
POSITION IN THE OFFICE WHOSE
JOB IT IS TO REDUCE THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE KITS BACKLOG.
FOR I HEARD THAT THEY DID NOT
CAROLINA THEY PROVIDED GRANTS
AND PUSH THEM OUT TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HELP WITH THE
PROCESSING AND TO REDUCE THE
BACKLOG SO I'M TAKING NOTES
ABOUT THE BEST IDEAS INVEST
APPROACHES TO HELP ADDRESS- AND
REDUCE AND REMOVE THAT BACKLOG
AND I'M COMMITTED TO. REMOVING
IT. THANK YOU. SOME OF. THANK
YOU MISTER LACK OF THIS CHAPTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FIRST OF
ALL CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION TO BE OUR NEXT EASY
ARE YOUR NOMINATION IS INDEED
HISTORIC IN THAT- YOU BE.
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF FILIPINO DESCENT AND
AS A MEMBER OF THE API
COMMUNITY I COULD NOT BE
PROUDER. OVER THE YEARS I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE- VIGOROUSLY
REPRESENTED YOUR CONSTITUENTS
AND CALIFORNIANS ON. MANY
IMPORTANT ISSUES- DRESSING
JUSTICE IN JUSTICES- ADVANCING
REFORMS JUST TO NAME A FEW. BOB
YOU'RE A PRAGMATIC APPROACH TO
RESOLVING ISSUES AND YOUR
ABILITY TO WORK WITH DIFFERENT
DIVERSE GROUPS OF STAKEHOLDERS
WILL NO DOUBT CONTINUE TO SERVE
YOU WELL. AS WELL AS THE STATE.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST
QUESTION DEALS WITH HATE CRIME
SO WHICH YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. I IN FACT OVER
THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE SEEN AS
SKYROCKETING OF RACIALLY
MOTIVATED HATE INCIDENTS
AGAINST ASIAN COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE STATE. AND THE NATION. THE
ORGANIZATIONS STOP EIGHTY P. I.
T. REPORTED ABOUT THE- FOUR
THOUSAND PIECES OF HATE RELATED
INCIDENTS OVER A TEN MONTH
PERIOD. AND THIS IS ONLY THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG. NOW THIS
ISSUE IS PERSONAL TO ME BUT-
THE SENTIMENT IS ALSO SHARED BY
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES BECAUSE-
WHEN THESE VIOLENT ACTS- I
COMMITTED THERE NOT. ONLY
IMPACTING THE INDIVIDUAL
VICTIMS AND ALSO THE COMMUNITY.
AT LARGE. HOWEVER MANY HATE
CRIMES AND VIOLENT ACTS ARE NOT
BEING REPORTED OR PROSECUTED
BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT TO PROVE
THE PERPETRATORS SO INTENT. MY
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD THE DOJ
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP. IMPROVE
THE DETECTION INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTION OF HATE CRIMES AND
HATE INCIDENTS. AND AS A COOK A
QUICK FOLLOW UP I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE RAPID RESPONSE TEAM
WITHIN THE DOJ FOCUSES ALL ONLY
ON A SERIOUS CRIMES. SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD THE DOJ
AGAIN UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
WORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO
ADDRESS HATE RELATED INCIDENTS.
THANK YOU SOME EVER TELL FOR
YOUR YOUR COMMENTS IN YOUR
QUESTION. FOR THE API COMMUNITY
RIGHT NOW WHEN IT COMES TO HATE
CRIMES WERE AN AWFUL STATE OF
CRISIS AND A FULL STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN MY HEART GOES OUT
TO. ALL OF THE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF HATE CRIMES
THROUGHOUT THIS NATION
INCLUDING IN ATLANTA- BUT ALSO.
IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN OAKLAND
AND SAN FRANCISCO AS YOU
MENTIONED THIS BEFORE THOUSAND
CASES. OVER THE PAST YEAR- FROM
C. SPITTING AND YELLING AT
INDIVIDUALS TO. PUNCH IN THE
FACE AND- WASHING THEM DOWN TO.
SLASHING HIM ACROSS THE FACE
AND MURDERING THEM. AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE HAVE A
PROBABLY HAD ALLIES AND MEMBERS
OF LEADERS NAY PI COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE LEADERS CONDEMN AND
DENOUNCE AND WE'RE ALSO BEEN
TAKING ACTION I KNOW THAT A
NUMBER OF YOU HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS. AT THE
STATE EMERGENCY THE STATE OF
CRISIS AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE PASSION ON THIS ISSUE AND
THE PROPOSAL OF SOLUTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD- THE DOJ.
CAN DO A NUMBER OF THINGS ONE
IS. HELP OTHER JURISDICTION'S
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFY AND
INVESTIGATE HATE CRIMES THAT IS
NOT ALWAYS SOMETHING. THAT IS
FOCUSED ON PRIORITIZED- AND LET
ME JUST BACK BACK UP ONE STEP
INTO SAFE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
ONE REALLY POINTING THE DOJ CAN
DO IS TO CARE. AND TO
PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
IT A TOP PRIORITY AND- THE
INVESTIGATION AND
IDENTIFICATION SHE WAS ONE
BUILDING STRONG RELATIONS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY SO THAT COMMUNITY
WILL COME FORWARD AND REPORT.
I'M SUPPORTING VICTIMS- IN
DIFFERENT WAYS WHETHER IT BE
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OR ACTION TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE FOR LANGUAGE
ACCESS- FOR SOME OF OUR API
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- FROM THAT
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE AND HELPFUL
AND THEN THE REPORTING SYSTEM
IS ALSO VERY IMPORTANT- I KNOW
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE PUT
FORWARD AN IDEA FOR A HE CAN
TIMELINE. I TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET ACCURATE REPORTING THEY
CAN DRIVE APPROPRIATE POLICY
AND INTERVENTION. SO- YOU KNOW
WE CAN PUT UP- TO ABOUT- TO
SHOW OTHER. THE BEST WAY TO
ADDRESS TAKE HOME SO WE CAN
SHOW THAT'S PACKED. ONE THING I
THINK IS SUPER. IS TO GET OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND LISTEN.
AND SEE COMMUNITY C. IMPACTS
MANY WHO'VE BEEN HURT. ASK WHAT
THEY NEED ASK WHAT- SUPPORT THE
DOJ CAN PROVIDE SO I KNOW
THAT'S A- RATHER- LONG MENU OF
OPTIONS. AND ACTIONS THAT THE
DOJ CAN TAKE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I'VE. THOUGHT ABOUT AND I
THINK ALL CAN ADD VALUE.
ANOTHER AREA OF INTEREST FOR ME
IS- DATA PRIVACY WHICH IS-
BECOMING MORE AND MORE.
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT. ALL PERSONAL INFORMATION
IS CONSTANTLY BEING COLLECTED
AND SHARED BY OTHERS- LAST YEAR
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. A PASSED
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR- WHICH
BASICALLY CREATED THE NEW A
NEW. PRIVACY PROTECTION AGENCY
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS. HOW DO
YOU FORESEE THE DOJ WORKING
WITH THIS NEW AGENCY- IN
ENFORCING CONSUMER PRIVACY LAWS
IN CALIFORNIA. JORDAN
COLLABORATIVELY WORKING
TOGETHER. AND WORKING AS A
TEAM- AS- DEFENDERS OF PRIVACY
AND SUPPORTERS OF CONSUMERS- I
KNOW THIS IS BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR YOU- AT AREA OF PASSION I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE SPACE. AND THE PROPOSITION
PROVIDES ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE NEW
PRIVACY AGENCY IT ALSO PROVIDES
A REAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THEY'RE COMMUNICATING
WORKING TOGETHER- MAKING SURE
THAT BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM.
ALL ISSUES THAT CAN BE
ADDRESSED ARE BEING ADDRESSED.
TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY OF
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA. I
THANK YOU. THIS WORKS. MISTER
CHAIR- EXCITED TO SEE YOU HERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AS MY
NEIGHBORING COLLEAGUES- WE
SHARE THE CITY OF THE GREAT
CITY OF OAKLAND- AND NOW YOU'RE
DISTRICTS CAN I GET A LOT
BIGGER- HERE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA- I HAVE FOUR
QUESTIONS- FOR YOU SOME OF
WHICH HAVE ALREADY. BEEN
ADDRESSED BY THE LITTLE BIT OF
A TRICK ON THEM I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO THE CONCERNS AND- HOPES
THAT- THE VIN REYES- BY- TO OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE APPS
PROGRAM ENSURING THAT- AND I
THINK IF YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION ADEQUATE I. TWENTY GO
ON THE RECORD SHOWING THAT
CONCERN AS WELL AND HOPEFULLY
HE WILL- IMPLEMENTS- ABSENT A
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WAY- ONE OF THE QUESTIONS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM AROUND IT.
DISCUSSED A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS
OF- THE GUN VIOLENCE DATA
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES THAT WE'RE
SEEING RECENT YOU KNOW NEWS
STORIES ABOUT DOJ- INCREASINGLY
BLOCK GUN VIOLENCE RESEARCHERS
ACCESS OF THE QUESTION THAT SHE
ASKED- WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
VERY CRITICAL TO UNDERSTANDING
THE IMPACT OF. GUN SAFETY LAWS.
I'M AS WELL AS THE GAPS IN
THOSE LAWS. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THERE'S A PART HAS ALSO
RECENTLY PROPOSED NEW
REGULATIONS THAT WOULD
FORMALISE THESE RESTRICTIONS-
AND SHOULD YOU- BECOME OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHICH IS A
PRETTY GOOD SENSE YOU WILL BE.
WOULD YOU REVERSE THOSE NEW
PROPOSALS OTHERS YOU PROPOSED
REGULATIONS AND INSTEAD YOU
KNOW REVIVED THE DEPARTMENT'S
LONGSTANDING PRACTICE OF MAKING
RELEVANT RECORDS. ACCESSIBLE TO
RESEARCH CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS FIRST DAY
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THE SPACE
FOR TO PROVIDE MORE GUN SAFETY
ADDRESSING GUN VIOLENCE FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY. AT THE BIG
LEADERS NATIONALLY IN THE
SPACE. AND WE KNOW THE RESEARCH
IS IMPORTANT AND MY GUT AND MY
HEART MY VALUES TELL ME. WE
SHOULD BE DISCLOSING AS MUCH
DATA AS LEGALLY PERMISSIBLE TO
THE RESEARCHERS TO AS YOU SAY
YOU HAVE GOT TO GUIDE US
IDENTIFY THE GAPS TELL US WHAT
POLICIES CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE- I HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT THAT THE REGULATIONS-
IF I AM CONFIRMED. WHEN I FIRST
ORDERS OF BUSINESS WILL BE TO
REVIEW THEM GET BRIEFED ON
THEM. NOW WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
AND WHY AND THEN MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT THEM THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH MY VALUES. I
ALSO KNOW THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING IS HELPING TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE THAT CAN PROVIDE CLARITY
AND I'VE ALSO EARD AND AS I'M
GETTING MY HEAD AROUND SORT OF-
THE POSSIBILITY OF A TWENTY
EXECUTIVE BRANCH THAT WHEN WE
AS LEGISLATORS. LEGISLATE WE DO
OUR BEST BUT THE BEST POLICY
INTO THE WORLD BUT WHEN IT'S
RECEIVED BY THE PERSON OR
ENTITY OR DEPARTMENT AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING.
THERE MIGHT BE SOME AMBIGUITY
THERE MIGHT BE AN UNATTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT CLEAR- AND
THAT AND- I WOULD ON ISSUES
THAT. IF I AM I HAVE THE HONOR
OF BEING CONFIRMED AS THE AG IT
IS AN ISSUE THAT RELATES TO
THAT APARTMENT I WOULD TRY TO.
WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
ADDRESS THOSE BEFORE THEY
BECOME LAW AND IF THEY DO
BECOME LAW- YOU KNOW WORK ON
THAT CLARIFICATION SO WE CAN
GET THE WHAT. GET TO THE GOAL
THE GOAL HERE IS TO GET
SUBSTANTIALAFFECTIVE HEALTH
RESEARCH I WANT TO GET TO THAT
GOAL AND I WORK WITH YOU TO GET
THERE. GREAT THANK YOU I WILL
WORK WITH YOU AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW- MY SECOND QUESTION IS
ABOUT DONOR ADVISED FUNDS WHICH
WAS RAISED- IN THE
PERSPECTIVES- FROM- ONE OF THE
WITNESSES EARLIER- AND I'VE
DONE SOME WORK IN THE SPACE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE- BUT JUST
AS A SORT OF REFER CALIFORNIA
FORGOES FORGOES. A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE OF ABOUT. THREE OR
FORTY MILLION A YEAR AND THE
GENERAL FUND REVENUE. TO
PROVIDE TERRIBLE DOT. FOR DONOR
BY FUND COUNTRY- WITH COMPARE.
BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC. WELL
DRAFT UNDERTAKEN IMMEDIATE TAX
DEDUCTION THERE IS NO GUARANTEE
THAT ANY DOUBT FUNDS WILL
ACTUALLY REACH CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS. THE MONEY
CONSIDER THE DEATHS. IN
PERPETUITY- MANY OF SOME OF THE
MONEY DOES MAKE IT INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND SOME OF IT
DOESN'T WE JUST DON'T KNOW
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
TRANSPARENCY- AROUND IT AND I
THINK ACCOUNTABILITY ON THIS
MONEY IS CRITICAL ESPECIALLY AS
WE'RE MAKING THIS DEAL THAT.
YOU KNOW A DONOR CAN GIVE A TAX
WRITE OFF THAT COMES OUT OF OUR
GENERAL FUND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY DIDN'T. MAKES IT
INTO THE NONPROFIT THAT ARE
SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES. AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOW YOU
UTILIZE YOUR AUTHORITY AS A
CHARITABLE TRUST REGULATOR TO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY
REPORTING. BY DONOR ADVISED
FUNDS ESPECIALLY WITH. THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LARGER
COMMERCIAL INVESTMENT BANKS.
LET ME START BY SAYING I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THE GOOD WORK
OF OUR- CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ON THE GROUND
HELPING PEOPLE- AND WE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A TAX CODE THAT ALLOWS
FOR- DONATIONS TO CHARITABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS FREE OF TAX IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK. AND. THAT THE
DONOR ADVISED FUND ISSUE THAT
YOU HAVE TO HELP ME UNDERSTAND
BETTER THANK YOU- YOU KNOW IT
YOU YOU BOOKED THE HEAD THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET. AND YOU- AND-
THE TAX WRITE OFF IS TAKEN BY
THE DONOR BUT THAT BUT THE
WHOLE REASON FOR THE POLICY. TO
HAVE- ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR CHARTER
ORGANIZATIONS DOING GOOD WORK
ON THE GROUND IS NOT REALIZED
YET. MAYBE IT WILL BE IN THE
FUTURE BUT IT HASN'T YET SO I
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM- I GUESS
MY- RESPONSE TO A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT WILL I DO IS I'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
IDENTIFY AND WHAT ARE THE BEST
PATHWAYS I LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE DOJ EXPERTS IN IN AND OUR-
YOU KNOW CHARTER ORGANIZATION
ACCOUNTABILITY GROUP TO GET
ADVICE ON WHAT TO THIRTY WE DO
HAVE I MEAN WHAT A THIRTY WE
MIGHT NEED. TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT- PARDON REVISED FUNDS
ARE WORKING IN A WAY THAT. ARE
RIGHT FOR THE STATE AND RECORDS
ARE BALKANIZATION. THINKING OF-
MOVING ON TO REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
KINGS COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
D. A. KEITH- BURGUNDY'S CHARGED
A DORA PREZ A TWENTY NINE YEAR
OLD WOMAN WITH MURDER AFTER SHE
EXPERIENCED A STILLBIRTH. A
YEAR LATER HE BROUGHT SIMILAR
CHARGES AGAINST CHELSEA BECKER
THAN TWENTY FIVE UNDER
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL FACTS BOTH
WOMEN. I HAVE A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER AND WERE REPORTED TO
THE POLICE BY STAFF AT
ADVENTIST HEALTH HANFORD
HOSPITAL. DURING HER INITIAL-
THE PROSECUTION THE DOOR OF HER
KAREZ RECEIVED INADEQUATE LEGAL
COUNSEL AND PLED GUILTY TO
MANSLAUGHTER FOR LOSING HER
FETUS A CRIME THAT DOESN'T
ACTUALLY EXIST IN CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS NOW THREE YEARS INTO
ELEVEN YEAR PRISON SENTENCE.
CHELSEA BECKER IS STILL
CHALLENGE YOUR PROSECUTION BUT
IS BEING HELD IN JAIL ON A TWO
MILLION DOLLAR BAIL WHICH DATE-
FIGURE THIS EXPLICITLY ARGUES.
IS TO QUOTE PREVENT THE
PROSPECT OF INSPECTOR BECOMING
PREGNANT AGAIN. THESE CASES
REPRESENT A GROWING EFFORT. ON
TOP OF THE WIDE SCALE ROWS OF
ABORTION RIGHTS TO CONTROL AND
REGULATE FORGET PEOPLE'S
BODIES. PRIOR TO THESE CASES
EVERY CALIFORNIA COURT THAT IS
TAKEN UP THIS QUESTION IS A
FIRM THAT WOMEN CANNOT BE
PROSECUTED FOR THE OUTCOMES OF
THEIR PREGNANCIES.
CRIMINALIZING PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES OPENS THE DOOR FOR THE
STATE TO INTERROGATE AND
PROSECUTE ANY ACTION THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY LEAK WILL. LEAD TO
A PREGNANCY LOSS. MISCARRIAGES
AND STILLBIRTHS ARE
UNFORTUNATELY COMMON OUTCOME OF
PREGNANCY AND THIS PRESIDENT
WOULD DISPROPORTIONATELY HARM
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES WHO
WAS A PRODUCT OF DECADES OF
STATE DISCRIMINATION ELECT.
HAVE ADEQUATE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND OTHER VITAL RESOURCES
THAT PLACE THEIR HEALTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK THOSE
CASES ARE ALARMING TO ME AND I
CAN'T BELIEVE THAT'S HAPPENING.
IN CALIFORNIA OR IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. SO AS AG-
THE CREDIT FORMER AG UP IS
THERE A FILED AN AMICUS BRIEF
EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR THESE
TWO WOMEN HELSEA AND ADORA WHO
HAVE BEEN ERRONEOUSLY
PROSECUTED FOR PREGNANCY LOSS.
IN THESE BRIEF HE AFFIRMED THAT
THE PORTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
PENAL CODE THAT APPLIES TO
FETAL MURDER EXPLICITLY
EXCLUDES THE PREGNANCY THE
PREGNANT PERSON'S. PERSONAL
SELVES FROM PROSECUTION UNDER
THE STATUTE WILL YOU COMMIT TO
CONTINUING SUPPORT FOR MISS
BACKER AND DISPERSED CASES AND
ANY OTHERS LIKE THIS. YES I DO
NOT AGREE WITH THE PROSECUTOR
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE IN
THOSE ASES I DO AGREE WITH THE
AMICUS BRIEF. SUBMITTED BY
TWENTY JOURNALISTS ARE. THANK
YOU AND JUST ONE LAST QUESTION-
POGOR POLICE OFFICER BILL
RATES- MANY ADVOCATES- HAVE
EXPRESSED DESIRE FOR REFORMS ON
THIS ESPECIALLY IN THE WAKE OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING IN TERMS
OF THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION-
AROUND POLICE BRUTALITY- I
WANTED TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU
ON DO YOU THINK COBAR NEEDS
REFORMS- AND IF SO DO YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC OFF ON IT. ALSO
GENERALLY WE'RE IN A- RACIAL
JUSTICE RECKONING AND A AND A
RECKONING ON ON HOW WE POLICE
AND WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S
NOT WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER WHAT
REFORM LOOKS LIKE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THE
CERTIFICATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS. LIKE SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE DISCLOSURE OF POLICE
PERSONNEL RECORDS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES- WE'RE TALKING
pSTATUTORY IMMUNITY IN CERTAIN
CASES THOSE OF THE RIGHT
DISCUSSIONS WE NEED TO. BE
THOUGHTFUL- BALLOTS- REFORM-
BALANCE IN OUR REFORM JUSTICE
AND FAIRNESS COMPASSION
HUMANITY AND MAKE SURE OUR WORK
SUPPORTING SAFETY AS WELL. AND
BUT FOR PROPOSALS THAT REFLECT
THOSE VALUES- OF JUSTICE AND
SAFETY OF FAIRNESS AND
COMPASSION SO. I THINK WHERE
WE'VE BEEN AND I'M PROUD THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN THIS BODY-
LEADERS IN THAT IN THAT
DISCUSSION. AND I THINK IT WILL
LEAD TO GOOD RESULTS. WELL I
APPRECIATED AND- TO BE MAKING
THREE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ALL THESE ISSUES AND
MANY MORE. THANK YOU FOR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU BUSINESS
HOURS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE WE
PLAYED PHONE TAG BUT DIDN'T GET
TO SPEAK BUT IF I TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT VIA TEXT AND REALLY HAVE
NO CONCERNS SO- I DIDN'T FEEL
IT WAS REALLY NECESSARY- MY
ONLY CONCERN WOULD BE OF COURSE
THAT YOU CONTINUE YOUR GREAT
ADVOCACY- THAT YOU EXPRESSED AS
A LEGISLATOR IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. I HAVE A
QUESTION- THAT WASN'T COVERED
BY ANY OF THE KIND OF GROUPS IN
AREAS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
OR WASN'T ASKED BUT AS YOU KNOW
AND BE PART OF THIS BODY- SINCE
WE FIRST GOT HERE THERE HAS
BEEN A SYSTEMATIC ATTACK ON
ENFORCEMENT. ANY TYPE OF
ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS AND
BILLS SO WHEN WE FIRST GOT HERE
IT WAS TAKING OUT THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION FOR WORKERS TO
PURSUE THEIR OWN INTEREST- THAT
THERE WAS THEN AN ATTACK
CONTINUES THE ATTACK ON PADA
WHICH ALLOWS YOU KNOW ATTORNEYS
TO BE PERSONALLY JEEZ- AND NOW
JUST RECENTLY WE SAW THE MOST
CRITICAL ATTACKS ON- FUNDING OF
THE LABOR AGENCY IN ORDER TO
ENFORCE LABOR LAWS. THAT BEING
SAID WE ALWAYS HAVE A BACKSTOPS
TO DETERMINE GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND- WE'VE BEEN WRITING IN THAT
BACKSTOPS MORE MORE LAWS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
THAT END- THE PREVIOUS ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YOU EVER SET UP
WAS AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER IN-
REALLY ESTABLISHING. STANDARDS
FOR A- INVESTIGATION AND
PROSECUTIONS- SCOPE IN FACT IN
JANUARY HE ESTABLISHED A WORKER
RIGHTS AND FAIR LABOR SECTION.
OF THE DOJ WHAT ARE NUMBER ONE
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS FOR THAT
SECTION. AND ARE YOU WILLING TO
CONTINUE- TO STAND UP AND
SOMETIMES STAND AGAINST YOU
KNOW VERY POWERFUL CORPORATIONS
WERE MISTREATING WORKERS- ON
BEHALF OF PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FOR. GIVE ME JUST A
YEAR YOUR FIERCE UNPARALLELED
LEADERSHIP SUPPORTING WORKERS
AND I AGREE WITH- THAT THE
VISION AND VALUES- ATTORNEY
GENERAL ETCETERA AND CREATING-
OTHER WORKERS RIGHT TO FAIR
LABOUR SECTION. AND I PLAN TO
CONTINUE. GRAYSON FOR HIM
STARTING IT AND USE IT TO
ADDRESS ANY ABUSES OR
MISTREATMENT OR HARM TO WORKERS
WHETHER THAT'S MISS
CLASSIFICATION OR WASTE AFTER
UNDERGOING CANNOT KANEMI OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING FOR LABOUR-
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS.
WORKERS DESERVE SUPPORT IT IS
OUR CHAMPION WILL DEFEND THEM
INTERVIEW MISTREATED AND ABUSED
SO I WILL LEAN INTO THAT WORK
AND BUILD ON THE GREAT WORK
ALREADY STARTED BY TWENTY
CAMPUS THAT. THANK YOU THIS
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- CONGRADULATIONS AS MANY
OF SAID ON YOUR ON YOUR
NOMINATION- THANK YOU I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR YOU I'VE
ENJOYED OUR TIME TOGETHER IS
COLLEAGUES LIKE WITH.
ANTICIPATED I'LL BE SAD TO SEE
GO- I DID HAVE A COUPLE. LINES
OF INQUIRY- ONE REGARDS THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND THE- THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT I BELIEVE
VERY IMPORTANT POSSIBILITY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CALIFORNIA TO
WRITE BALLOT MEASURE TITLES AND
SUMMARIES FOR STATEWIDE
INITIATIVES- IN FACT UNDER THE
ELECTION CODE SECTION NINE ZERO
FIVE ONE C. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REQUIRED BY LAW TO
DRAFT QUOTE TRUE AND IMPARTIAL.
IN QUOTE TITLES AND SUMMARIES.
THAT ARE NOT QUOTE LIKELY TO
CREATE PREJUDICE FOR OR AGAINST
THE PROPOSED MEASURE- IT HAS
BEEN OBSERVED BY SOME. IT'S MY
PERSONAL OPINION THAT NOT EVERY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST THIS- THE STATE
FAITHFUL TO THIS LEGAL
REQUIREMENT. ELECTION CODE AND
I'M NOT ALONE IN THAT OPINION
THE MERCURY NEWS EDITORIAL
BOARD IN TWENTY TWENTY- CALLED
OUT TO A PARTICULAR BALLOT
DESCRIPTION AS TRICKING THE
ELECTRIC. AND SAID THE DISTRUST
THE GOVERNMENT CAN SPILL OVER
INTO OTHER ISSUES IN THE
CONSEQUENCES CAN BE SEVERE. AND
THE L. A. TIMES EDITORIAL BOARD
ALSO WROTE LAST FALL. THAT A
PARTICULAR. BALLOT MEASURE FOR
CERTAIN FORSAKES IMPARTIALITY
IN FAVOR OF LOADED AND
MISLEADING LANGUAGE DESIGNED TO
SWAY. VOTERS THE BOTH OF THOSE
EDITORIAL BOARDS THOSE PAPERS
CALLED ON A BALLOT INITIATIVE
IRONICALLY TO BE PLACED ON THE
BALLOT FOR VOTERS TO TAKE THE
ROLE OF DRAFTING THE DAUGHTER
OF SUMMARY AWAY FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND PUT IT IN
THE NONPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. OTHER PLACES
YOU COULD GO BUT THAT. MAKE
CERTAIN ASSETS SIDE COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOLLOWING UP ON THAT
BACKGROUND MATERIAL THE FIRST
IS- DO YOU AGREE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD HAVE%
THE ROLE. OF DRAFTING BALLOT
TITLE AND SUMMARY. WOULD YOU BE
OPEN TO IT- TO A REFORM IN THAT
REGARD THAT WOULD PUT IT WITH
THE L. A. O. THE- FIRST
QUESTION THE SECOND QUESTION
IS- I GUESS. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE
EVERYBODY LIKES A LOADED BALLOT
TITLE AND SUMMARY WHEN IT GOES
THE WAY THEY WANT ON THE
INITIAL- BUT THAT. IS A DOUBLE
EDGED SWORD AND LONG RUN. MY
FEAR IS. THAT IF THIS IMPORTANT
SACRED DUTY THAT IS VESTED
RIGHT NOW WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO WRITE A TRULY- TRUE
AND IMPARTIAL TITLE AND SUMMARY
THAT DOESN'T PROJECTS WHEN
WE'RE NOT. IS NOT HEATED IT
WILL UNDERMINE A COREFUNCTION
AND TRUST IN THE CORE FUNCTION
OF OUR UNIQUE DIRECT DEMOCRACY
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS. PART AND
PARCEL OF HAVINGA STRONG
DEMOCRACY- SO I'M LOOKING FOR
AN ANSWER TO THE FIRST QUESTION
AS TO WHETHER YOU THINK THAT
THAT ROLES REMAIN WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE OPEN TO
THAT CHANGING AND THE AND THEN
I'M LOOKING FOR. A COMMITMENT
TO THE BEST OF YOUR ABILITY TO
DISCHARGE THIS DUTY UNDER THE
ELECTION CODE NINE ZERO FIVE
ONE C. IN THE BEST WAY YOU
POSSIBLY CAN TO BE TRULY. A
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL. THANK YOU.
HI FOR CENTER STAND IN
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE IMPACT ON. TRUST AND IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS. AND
RIGHT NOW- THE LAW IS THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- PREPARES THE
TITLE AND SUMMARY I BELIEVE. IF
I HAVE DONE A BILL WOULD HAVE
BEEN CONFIRMED THAT I. CAN AND
WILL- DISCHARGED THAT DUTY I
TRUTHFULLY. AND IMPARTIALLY
FAIRLY. AND ACCURATELY AND- YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING WE SPOKE
THAT I THOUGHT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TALKING ABOUT- USING
LANGUAGE THAT IS INFORMATIVE
AND HELPFUL. AND CLEAR AND NOT
CONFUSING FOR VOTERS THAT- THAT
THE TITLE SUMMARY SHOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR TO VOTERS WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON CAMPAIGNS ARE FOR
PERSUASION TITLE AND SUMMARY IS
FOR. UNDERSTANDING THE ISSUE.
AND THE JOB OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS TO CALL BALLS AND
STRIKES WHEN IT COMES THE TITLE
AND SUMMARY AND I'M I BELIEVE
THAT I CAN AND WILL. I DO THAT
QUICKLY AND IMPARTIALLY AND
FAIRLY IF I. HAD THE HONOR OF
BEING CONFIRMED. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANSWER I AGREE WITH YOU
AND I LOVE THE DESCRIPTION OF
CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES I
THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE-
ELECTION CODE CALLS ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO DO- MY
OTHER LINE ANGRY REGARDS- ANTI
TRUST LAW AND THE ROLE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- THE SHORT
ANSWER THE SHORT VERSION THIS
QUESTION THAT I'VE- GOT A
LITTLE ABERRATION- IS ARE YOU
WILLING TO LOOK AT MODERN.
GIANT TECHNOLOGICAL TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES THROUGH A MAYBE
NONTRADITIONAL. LANCE AND THE
REASON I ASK THAT IS. A MULTI
FACTORED- ONE IS WE'VE STARTED
WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE
INTERESTS ABOVE THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND STATE LEVEL OF
LOOKING AT SORT OF- THE POWER
AND SIZE OF CERTAIN GIANT TECH
COMPANIES MANY OF WHOM. WERE
BORN AND BRED AND RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME- WE ALSO HAVE A LONG
TRADITION CALIFORNIA IT'S IN
OUR- STATE CONSTITUTION THAT
THERE'S A RIGHT TO PRIVACY-
IT'S IMPORTANT. TO CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE PRIVACY- IN THEIR DATA
IN THEIR HOMES. AND OTHER OTHER
THINGS OF THAT NATURE- AND
THERE'S BEEN LAWSUIT CERTAIN
LAWSUITS BROUGHT BY ATTORNEYS
GENERAL FROM. I THINK THAT'S
THE RIGHT WAY TO SAY IT
ATTORNEYS GENERAL. FROM
ACTUALLY ALL FIFTY STATES- THE
RECENTLY ALLEGING ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRACTICES BUT
CERTAIN COMPANIES- PUTS PERHAPS
CALIFORNIA IN A BIT OF A HOT
SEAT BECAUSE THESE ARE OUR
COMPANIES- BUT I THINK IT'S
RATHER IMPORTANT- CALIFORNIA
BECAME IN DECEMBER THE LAST
STATE ACTUALLY TO JOIN. THAT
FIFTY STATE LAWSUIT- AND MANY
PEOPLE HAVE ARGUED THAT ARE AN
INTEREST LAWS BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE THE CARD RIGHT ACT AS THE
STATE VERSION OR MAYBE. THIS
THING RINGING LIKE CRAZY- ARE
MAY BE IN NEED OF A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF MODERNIZATION TO
BETTER FIT THE BUSINESS MODELS
OF THESE. COMPANIES FOR
INSTANCE UNDER. THE SHERMAN AND
CLAYTON ACTS OF FEDERAL LAW THE
WAY YOU LOOK AT WHETHER
COMPANIES A MONOPOLY. IS YOU
LOOK AT THEIR MARKET POWER AND
SIZE ONE INTO YOU LOOK AT
WHETHER THEY'RE ABLE TO RAISE
PRICES WITHOUT LOSING CUSTOMERS
WELL THAT DOESN'T FIT REAL WELL
WHEN. THE COMPANY'S OFFER
PRODUCTS OR SERVICES FOR WHICH
THEY DO NOT CHARGE ANYTHING IT
IS A FREE PRODUCT AND SERVICE.
AND THEY MAKE THEIR MONEY. AND
A CONSIDERABLE GOBS OF IT AT
THAT BY USING PEOPLE'S DATA AND
USER DATA THAT THEY DERIVE
THROUGH THE USE OF THAT
PRODUCT. BOB SO I THINK WE'VE
GONE FOR FORTY YEARS OR SO
UNDER THE CHICAGO SCHOOL MODEL
AND LOOKING AT. THE CHICAGO
SCHOOL ECONOMICS WAY OF
DEFINING A MONOPOLY. AND MAYBE
OUR STATUTES NEED TO BE UPDATED
MAYBE THEY NEED TO BE
MODERNIZED. AND I SEE THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT A
CRITICAL ONE. OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND SAFEGUARDING
THAT PRIVACY THAT CALIFORNIANS
EXPECT- IN THEIR DATA AND THEIR
HOME IN THE USE OF THEIR
DEVICES AND SO ON SO FORTH. SO
LONG WINDED QUESTION BUT IT
COMES DOWN TO ARE YOU OPEN TO
EXAMINING WHETHER CALIFORNIA'S
ANTI TRUST LAWS SHOULD BE
REFORMED OR MODERNIZE ALONG
THOSE LINES- AND MAYBE THERE
MAYBE THERE ADEQUATE BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT. AND
SECONDLY MORE GENERALLY WHAT
ARE YOUR ROLE WHAT ARE YOUR
VIEWS ON THE ROLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL. IN
PROTECTING CONSUMER PRIVACY.
THANK YOU. I THINK THAT THE
IMPORTANT GOAL IS TO KEEP IN
MIND OUR- BACK TO THAT FRAME I
HAD ABOUT WHAT I THINK THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ROLE IS. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ROLE THIS
TIME JERRY. IN A BROADLY
SPEAKING PROTECT A LITTLE BACK.
AGAINST OVERREACH AND ABUSE OF
POWER BY THE BIG GUY. AND IT
COULD TAKE A LOT OF FORMS-
CERTAINLY- IF A COMPANY IS-
OVERSTEPPING ITS ITS LEGAL
AUTHORITY IF IT IS ENGAGE IN
ANTI COMPETITIVE PRACTICES IT
IS IF IT IS VIOLATING CONSUMER
PRIVACY BECAUSE ABUSING
CONSUMERS AND OTHER WAYS. AND
IN VIOLATION OF THE LAW IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE THEY'RE
FROM OR HOW BIG THEY ARE- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL- AND IT SHOULD
I HAVE THE HONOR OF BEING
CONFIRMED SHOULD. TAKE ON. THAT
COMPANY AND GO WITH A LAN FACTS
TAKE THEM. IN SO. I THINK IT IS
THE ROLE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
FROM ABUSE. BY ANY POWERFUL
ABUSERS THAT COULD BE TECH
COMPANIES IF THE LAW AND THE
FACTS. ARE DETERMINED SO HERE
THE POINT IS ABOUT ADVOCACY OF
THE LAW ATTENTION NEED FOR
MODERNIZATION. I THINK IT'S A
REALLY INTERESTING INSIGHT
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY BEEN VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS AND LOOK
INTO THIS ISSUE- I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER. BUT I DO- I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT THAT-
BIG TECH COMPANIES THEIR
BUSINESS MODELS THEIR BUSINESS
APPROACHES. ARE DIFFERENT
PERHAPS THAN OIL AND STILL
COMPANIES FROM DECADES AGO. AND
THE- ORIGINAL GOAL THAT WE HAD
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM PRICE
GOUGING ANTI COMPETITIVE
PRACTICES AND THE ABUSE OF
MONOPOLIES- THAT SHOULD BE
MAINTAINED THAT PROTECTION. AND
I THINK IT WILL REQUIRE SOME
ADDITIONAL THINKING AND
COLLABORATING AROUND WHETHER
IT'S NECESSARY AND IF SO WHAT
THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR OBSERVATION.
THAT'S THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS
I HAVEN'T THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THOSE ANSWERS I- I HOPE YOU
KEEP THOSE THINGS IN MIND- I'D
ASK THAT YOU DO AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD INTO. WHAT I ANTICIPATE
WILL BE A SUCCESSFUL. NEW
DIRECTION. THANK YOU SENATE
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM WE HAVE BEEN
AT THIS FOR A LITTLE WHILE MOST
OF BONTA I THINK WE OWE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK BEFORE WE
CONTINUE. SO WHAT ARE WE- TAKE
FIVE OR TEN MINUTES AND GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO. RELAXER EVEN
STATED FOR QUITE A TIME SO
LET'S TAKE FIVE OR TEN MINUTES
AND THEN WE'LL- THEN WE'LL WRAP
UP IF THAT'S OKAY ITH YOU.
ABSOLUTELY I'D FOR THE CHECK
THANK YOU.
SH WITH KOMBUCHA WE
COME BACK TO ORDER. AND FINISH.
OUR TASK HERE TODAY. SO NEXT I
THINK THE CULTURE OF MR JONES
SAWYER AND I HAVE A FEW FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS. AND THEN I WILL
LOOK FOR A MOTION AND I WOULD
THEN LIKE TO GIVE MR BONTA THE
LAST WORD. BEFORE WE TAKE A
VOTE AND THEN WRAP UP THAT'S
THE PLAN SO THIS JONES SAWYER
THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU MR
BONTA UNITED CAME IN TOGETHER
AND IN TWENTY TWELVE. AND WE'VE
WE'VE DONE A LOT- I DON'T THINK
MANY PEOPLE KNOW AND I JUST
COULDN'T MAKE SURE A LOT OF
THINGS ON THE RECORD. AND- LIKE
YOU'RE YOU ARE ONE OFTHE
FOUNDING FATHERS OF CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE BONTA.
COOLEY JONES SAWYER BLACKIE AND
WOOD WHERE ONCE THE ROAD TO THE
LAWS FOR CANNABIS. SO IN THAT-
APART THAT DISCUSSION THAT YOU
HAD WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE.
I KNOW FROM ALL OF US THAT
WORKED ON IT WE WANT TO GET RID
OF THE ILLEGAL MARKET. AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU.
PEOPLE KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT
JUST COMMITTED TO IT BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BUT
YOU ARE FULLY VESTED IN IT
BECAUSE YOU STARTED. THE WHOLE
THING. SO IF YOU JUST JUST LET
US KNOW- AND I ALSO HAVE.
TALKED WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BEFORE. ABOUT GETTING
THEM ENOUGH RESOURCES AND MONEY
TO SHUT DOWN THE ILLEGAL
MARKET. BY SHUTTING DOWN THEIR
CASH FLOW. NOTHING IN THE JAIL-
AND I KNOW I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO
SAY THINGS LIKE ASSET
FORFEITURE. BUT IF WE- TAKE
AWAY LANDLORDS ASSETS WE GOING
HERE AND TO START SHUTTING DOWN
THE MARKET DOWN IN AND TAKING
WHAT THEY USE TO MAKE THEIR
PROFIT AWAY FROM THEM. I'VE
BEEN LANDLORDS WOULD BE LESS.
MMHM RIVERA RESISTED THE TO DO
THAT SO I JUST WANTED YOU TO
COMMENT ON THAT JUST REAL QUICK.
MY COMMENT IS I AGREE WITH WITH
WITH YOU WITH YOUR OBSERVATION.
ACTUALLY THE POINT THAT- YOU
KNOW. I'M COMMITTED TO THIS
FROM BEGINNING TO END AND WE
HELP WITH THE BEGINNING THAT
WILL HELP CREATE THAT THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS OF THE
REGULATED MARKET PLACE AND I'M
COMMITTED TO SEEING IT SUCCEED.
ONE CRITICAL COMPONENT TO MAKE
IT SUCCEED IS TO STOP THE PART
THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE FROM
UNDERMINING THE REGULATED
MARKET PLACE SO. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AROUND- RESOURCES IN YOUR-
VALUES AROUND NOT PUTTING
PEOPLE IN JAIL. BUT ANY LISTEN
MARKETPLACE THROUGH OTHER MEANS.
THANK YOU AND SO I WANT TO JUST
MAKE SURE WE JUST REITERATE OF.
ABOUT A FIFTY FIVE THINGS BAD
APPS THAT APPLE'S BAD CITIES
THAT DEPARTMENTS AND YOU JUST
FASTER BOB THAT CANNABIS- AS
YOU PROBABLY HEARD DESPITE FROM
EVERYBODY HERE AND AS YOU KNOW
WHEN WE GOT HERE. WE WERE TOLD
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
THEY WOULD GET THEY WOULD FIX
APPS GIVES ENOUGH TIMES AND WE
WOULD FIX IT. AND SO WHAT I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU IS NOT ONLY DO
YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT TO FIX IT.
BUT YOU GIVE US MEASURES OF
SUCCESS ON HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
FIX IT. SO THAT. AS I THINK YOU
SAID IN WHEN YOUR STATEMENTS-
YOU BELIEVE THAT WE CLEANED
OFF. THE LIST BUT THEN MORE
CAME IN- I DON'T THINK THIS
LEGISLATURE KNEW THAT. INSTEAD
BY THE TIME WE HEARD ABOUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON AGAIN IT WAS AT
THE SAME NUMBER SO THAT WAS
KIND OF THE FRUSTRATION WE GAVE
YOU TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT YOU GAVE AGES TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THERE WAS SOME
SUCCESS. BUT THEN THE BACKLOG
CAME UP AGAIN. I THINK JUST
JUST IF YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT.
TO LET US KNOW EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY OR ASSIGN SOMEBODY TO
LET THIS LEGISLATURE NO. NOT
ONLY WILL WE MAY EVEN GIVE MORE
MONEY. BUT WE MAY BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT- INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
GET THIS DONE. AND WE CAN BE-PARTNERS IN EVENTUALLY LEARNING
TO LISTEN BECAUSE WE HEAR A LOT
FROM. OUR COLLEAGUES- MAY NOT
BE SO- ENAMORED WITH GUN
CONTROL. THAT WHY WE GOING
AFTER THE BAD GUYS WELL THIS IS
A PERFECT EXAMPLE LET'S GO
AFTER THE BAD GUYS WITH GUNS.
LET'S MAKE A VALIANT EFFORT TO
GET THAT DONE SO. HOPEFULLY I
GET YOUR COMMITMENT ON THAT. IT
I. THANK TO WITH YOU TO THE
APPS ISSUE- I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE METRICS-
INTERNALLY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF
BEING CONFIRMED AND ALSO.
EXPRESSED TWO PARTNERS AND
LEGISLATURE LIKE YOU CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT THIS. I THINK ONE
OF THE I THOUGHT SOME UNIQUE
ABOUT ABOUT ME THAT'S BEEN MY
GOOD FORTUNE IS THAT- MY
PATHWAY. TO THIS NOMINATION HAS
BEEN THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
THROUGH WORKING WITH WITH YOU.
ALL OF THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE IN
OUR CLASS. BY THE NUMBERS ON
THIS FLOOR ON THE OTHER FLOOR.
AND I'VE LEARNED. SO MUCH FROM
FROM MY COLLEAGUES I'VE I'VE
SEEN THINGS DIFFERENTLY I'VE
GROWN AS A LEADER. AND I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP AND-
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I DON'T
WANT THAT PARTNERSHIP TO END.
IF I AM CONFIRMED. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER. ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
HAVE A COMMON GOAL LIKE
REDUCING. THE APPS LIST TO THE
LOWEST AMOUNT POSSIBLE SO. I
INVITE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY METRICS.
AND TAB. I BE SUCCESSFUL AND
HAVE US UNDERSTAND COMMUNICATE
WITH ONE ANOTHER WHAT THAT
SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE. J. AND THEN
BAD APPLES ESPECIALLY IN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT- IT IS. IT HURTS
THEM. MORE THAN IT IT HURTS US
BECAUSE THE INTEGRITY. OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS IT GOES DOWN-
AND THEY START TO LOSE THAT- I
THINK IT JUST. DISRUPTS THE
WHOLE PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM. IT
JUST MAKES IT A LITTLE MORE
SKEWS SO- IF EVERYONE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT DETAINEE GENERAL'S
OFFICE. AND US IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IF WE WORK REAL
HARD TO AS YOU YOU SAID. WE'RE
NOT LOOKING AT A LOT OF PEOPLE-
BUT 1% OF ANY GROUP. COULD
BECOME VERY PROBLEMATIC ONE
PERCENT. OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY.
THEN WE ALL GET PAINTED. WITH
THE SAME BRUSH THAT THEY'RE ALL
THAT WAY. AND SO WE BOTH.
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE. TO
BE IN. IN A BUBBLE AND HAVE
PEOPLE LOOK AT A SO- I
PURCHASED MY TO COMMIT THAT. WE
AGGRESSIVE- GO AFTER AND
PROSECUTE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY NOT SHOULD NOT FROM THE
BEGINNING EVER BECOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS- AND THAT
WE GET MORE PEACE OFFICERS IN
SO WE JUST PROFESSIONAL ICE-
THE ORGANIZATIONS. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY THAT
HAS THE TRUST OF. THE COMMUNITY
AT LARGE AND THAT TAKES A
DIFFERENT FORMS PART OF IT IS
APPROPRIATE TRAINING AND
SUPPORT- PART OF IT IS
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I KNOW
YOU'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY SO MINE CANNOT
CAN REALLY HELPS LEAD TO TRUST
SO STANDING A BABY FIFTEEN OH
SIX DECERTIFICATION- THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION SO I AM COMMITTED
TO GETTING. BUILDING THAT TRUST-BACK INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE COMMUNITY AND TAKING
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO GET THERE.
AND THEN UP. WHICH YOU MAY NOT
KNOW WE HAVE BAD CITIES. AT THE
LOWER SOUTHERN IN OF MY
DISTRICT. YOU'VE HEARD OF
BEFORE THE BELL BELL GARDENS
AND JUST RECENTLY THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE. ABOUT HUNTINGTON PARK
WHICH IS A PART OF MY WHERE.
THEY'RE THEY'RE OFFERING BUDGET
FOR PERSONNEL IS FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. BUT THE WHOLE
FINANCE DEPARTMENT WAS RAIDED
BY THE FBI BECAUSE THEY SENT IN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR Y.
TRANSFER. TO NEW YORK TO FOR
GOD KNOWS WHAT- SO THAT
OBVIOUSLY NO ACCOUNTABILITY BUT
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR ALL
THOSE CRESCENT CITIES BECAUSE
OF THE CORRUPT CRESCENT MOON-
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN SO MANY.
CITIES DOWN THERE AND ALMOST
LIKE IN A BUBBLE AND NOBODY THE
DA'S OFFICE- ORDER. OR EVEN FBI
OR EVEN THE AG'S OFFICE HAVE
PUT IN RESOURCES SO BEFORE YOUR
PREDECESSOR LEFT- I OFFERED
HIM. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
GIVE THEM MORE MONEY AND
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY GO IN
THERE BECAUSE- LOOK THEY'RE
STEALING MONEY FOR. FOR LATINO
AFRICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE JUST
JUST BEFORE THEY THEY- THEY
CAN'T COME TO A MEETING LIKE
THIS. AND THERE'S LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL THEY GOTTA WORK. AND SO
THEY CAN'T KEEP AN EYE ON-
PEOPLE WHO ARE ROBBING THE CITY
BLIND. SOMETIMES TWENTY MEAN
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH THE DEBT AND THEY HIDE
BECAUSE- NO ONE'S REALLY MAKING
A VALIANT EFFORT AND SO I WOULD
HOPE. WORKING WITH THE DA'S
OFFICE- IN LOS ANGELES WE CAN
FINALLY PUT JUSTICE CORRUPT
PRESIDENT OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT IT IT
JUST ALSO MAKE PEOPLE NOT TRUST
GOVERNMENT. AND ALL SO
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN COME UP WITH
SOME SOME WAYS TO DO THAT I'VE
ALSO OFFER THE TWO DID NOT
LIKE. THAT TO SEE IF WE HAVE
SURPLUS. AFTER WE NEED TO PUT
MORE MONEY IN THOSE DIRECTIONS
AND IN CITIES. THAT WE KNOW.
ARE ARE HAVING REAL FINANCIAL.
PROBLEMS CORRUPTION. THANK YOU
FOR IDENTIFYING THAT THAT HAS
ISSUE OF BETWEEN PEOPLE IN THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE THAT'S RIGHT.
AND IT'S A RISK COURSE WHEN
THERE'S PUBLIC CORRUPTION WHEN
THERE'S MISUSE OF PUBLIC FUNDS
WHEN THERE'S EMBEZZLEMENT. I
DIDN'T THINK THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT IS AN AREA OF
OVERLAPPING SURE JURISDICTION
AS YOU IDENTIFY WITH DA'S
HAVING JURISDICTION THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS WELL. AND I'D
LIKE TO SEE WHAT OUR OPERATION
LOOKS LIKE IN THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IF I HAVE THE HONOR OF
BEING CONFIRMED AND SEEING HOW
WE CAN BE PART. OF ROOTING OUT
PUBLIC CORRUPTION IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL INCLUDING IN THE AREAS
THAT YOU'VE DISCUSSED. THANK
YOU AND- THE LAST THING IS- WE
GOT CLEAN OUR OWN HOUSE- YOU
KNOW- I KNOW THAT THE AG'S
OFFICE. YEARS HOPEFULLY SOON TO
BE YOUR OFFICE. HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL THE AS ACROSS
THE STATE- ON D. E. D. D.
PROBLEM. SLASH CDC ARE
PROBLEMS. OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT HAVE BEEN
DEFRAUDED- FROM FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. AND WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU GET DOWN IN THE PROBLEM YOU
WONDER NOT ONLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN THE OUTSIDE. BUT
EVIDENTLY. SOME OF OUR
EMPLOYEES MAY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED AND I HOPE THAT WE
JUST DON'T. JUST DON'T. I DON'T
OVERLOOK IT. LET IT GO BY COULD
YOU CAN GET THE MONEY BACK OR
WHATEVER- BUT THAT WE SERIOUSLY
LOOK AT WHO DEFRAUDED US THAT
WE FULLY GO AFTER WHETHER THEY
WERE IN CDCR. WHETHER D. THAT
WE GO AFTER THAT CORRUPTION WE
CLEAN UP OUR OWN HOUSE. OUR OWN
HOUSE AND MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STAND FOR IT
ANYMORE A LOT OF TIMES
GOVERNMENTS TRY TO SWEEP IT
UNDER THE RUG. BECAUSE IT'S
EMBARRASSING IT IS
EMBARRASSING. BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE IF YOU PROSECUTE PEOPLE
WHO DO MALFEASANCE AND FRAUD IN
GOVERNMENT. IS SEND A MESSAGE
TO THE OTHERS DID NOT DO IT AND
SO HOPE I GET YOUR COMMITMENT
TO ALSO- AND I KNOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE ATTORNEY FOR
US. HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
IS CONSTITUTIONALLY OR- ITS
BUYOUT. TALK PRACTICE OF POLICY
BUT YOU ARE TECHNICALLY OUR
LAWYER WHEN YOU COME A G. BUT
WE ALSO NEED SOMEONE THAT CAN
KEEP US IN CHECK. I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE THAT- THESE
FUNDS THAT ARE MEANT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PAY THEIR NEXT MONTH'S
RENT OR THE BUTTON ON THEIR
TABLE WHO DESPERATELY ARE IN
NEED OF A EASY CHECK IT THAT
IT'S BEEN THE STOLEN THAT'S
BEEN DEFRAUDED THESE ARE ALSO
PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS TAXPAYERS
MONEY THAT'S BEEN- STILL STOLEN
AND MISUSED. AND FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING THERE ARE TRANS
NATIONAL CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS
INVOLVED AND IT INVOLVES I
THINK A MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
STRATEGY- WORKING WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WHO WHO ARE
WORKING ON THIS WORKING WITH
OTHER STATES OTHER STATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL- PERHAPS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
THAT INVESTIGATION AND I DO THE
BEST WE CAN TO- RECOVER IN
RECOUP- THE FACT THAT STATE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND ALL GO
WHEREVER. ON THIS ISSUE OVER
THE LONG THE FAX LEAD- I'M NOT
AWARE OF GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
BEING INVOLVED BUT I'LL GO
WHEREVER THE FACTS IN THE LEAD
AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT GET
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. AND- TRY TO REMEDY
THIS THE HORRIBLE- VIOLATION OF
TRUST AND AFTER THESE CRITICAL
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT SHOULD BE
IN THE POCKETS OF. CALIFORNIANS
IN NEED. YOU'LL YOU'LL FIND IT
GOES IS PRETTY PERVASIVE AND
THROUGHOUT. STATE GOVERNMENT SO.
THE VISION ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER- MISS BONTA
JUST TO A FEW MORE QUESTIONS
REALLY KIND OF CLARIFICATION
AND I THINK WHAT'S TRUE IS MOST
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED WERE INDIVIDUAL INTERESTS
OF LEGISLATORS. BUT I THINK A
LOT OF COMMON INTEREST FOR MOST
OF THIS. PERFECT NOT TO BEAT A
DEAD HORSE BUT THE IT'S LIKE
THE APPS PROCESS AND THE
FRUSTRATION THAT SITTING ON
SOME FIVE WE'VE HAD AS WE TRY.
TO PUSH THAT ISSUE AND YET THE
REALITY IS WE WE'RE HEARING
THOSE OF US. ESPECIALLY IN IN
SO WITH SOME RURAL DISTRICTS.
CARING DIFFERENT THINGS FROM
SHERIFF'S AND IN AND LOCAL
POLICE OFFICERS ABOUT. THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN TRYING TO GET
GUNS OUT OF PEOPLE'S HANDS AND
SO THE NOTION OF COMMUNICATING
WITH THE LOCAL AGENCIES IN
PROVIDING SOME SUPPORT AND SOME
HELP I THINK IT'S IT IS REALLY
A KEY ONE THERE BUT JUST A-
COUPLE OF CLARIFICATIONS AND
YOU HAD MENTIONED. THE SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WHERE
WE WERE TRYING TO MAKE IT CLEAR
ON THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. THAT WE WANTED
INFORMATION TO HELP. LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCOUNTABLE AND
YOUR PREDECESSOR TOOK THE- I
TOOK THE POSITION THAT I THINK
I THINK INCORRECTLY THAT IT
APPLIED ONLY TO CURRENT EVENTS
OR TO FUTURE RECORDS AS OPPOSED
TO REALLY GOING INTO THE DATA
ABOUT POLICE MISCONDUCT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL WANTED TO
DO. AND IT REALLY BEGS THE
QUESTION. YOU NOW IF YOU GET
THIS CONFIRMATION WILL BE IN
DOING AN ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE WE
BEING LEGISLATIVE AND NOT TO
UNDERMINE. THE SEPARATION OF
POWERS HERE. BUT HOW HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS AND WE FEEL ARE
FAIRLY CLEAR. THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE THAT WITH YOU AND I
THINK IT IS VERY FRUSTRATING
FOR US WHEN IN ADMINISTRATIVE
DEPARTMENT. TAKES A COUNTER.
INTERPRETATION OF THE STATUTE
NOT BASED ON THE WORDS OF THE
STATUTE BUT IT'S WOULD BE BASED
ON. ANOTHER DESIRE HOW DO WE
SORT THAT. LET ME TRY TO ANSWER
SPECIFICALLY FIRST AND
GENERALLY SECOND WHEN IT COMES
TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE. AS
PART OF THAT BILL- IT WAS A
BILL WHOSE LETTER AND INTENT
WAS FOR DISCLOSURE OF
ADDITIONAL PERSONAL RECORDS
PERSON PURSUANT TO THAT THE
CATEGORIES. ANIMATED IN THAT IN
THAT LAW. AND. HI IF I HAVE THE
HONOR OF BEING CONFIRMED I HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE ON THAT
DISCLOSURE PURSUANT TO LINE
CARRY OUT THE LAW. THERE THERE
WERE SOME. RUSSIANS ABOUT
WHETHER. IT WAS APPLIED TO
PROSPECTIVE RECORDS ONLY VERSUS
RETROSPECTIVE WHETHER IT
APPLIED TO. DOCUMENTS THAT THAT
WERE ARE CREATED- AN ACTUAL DOJ
DOCUMENTS OR DOCUMENTS IN THE
POSSESSION OF THE DOJ THAT WERE
THIRD PARTY DOCUMENTS THAT'S
ALL CLEARED UP NOW AS I
UNDERSTAND IT SO OR OR OR
CLOSER TO DISCLOSURE. AND
THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE BILL
OF LAW AND THAT'S WHAT I WILL
SEEK TO BE- PARTICIPATING IN
DISCLOSING THE BILL'S PURSUANT
TO THAT LAW. GENERALLY
SOMETIMES WE WRITE BILLS AS
LEGISLATORS AND I'VE DONE THIS-
WHERE WE THINK WE HAVE A TAPE
AND IT HAS ALL THE COMPONENTS
OF THE GUIDANCE NEEDED AND THE
SOMETHING THAT I JUST NEVER
THOUGHT OF. AND WHEN THE AGENCY
OR DEPARTMENT RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING- SEES THE BILL
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT AN
ANTENNA CONSEQUENCE OR
AMBIGUITY OR LACK OF CLARITY I
THINK I HOPE I BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN AVOID THAT. IF WE'RE
ENGAGED EARLIER MEANING IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
LEGISLATIVE TEAM ARE WORKING
WITH LEGISLATORS CARRYING BILLS
THAT IMPACT APARTMENT JUSTICE
TO- YOU KNOW PROVIDE INPUT TO
PROVIDE SUGGESTIONS TO POINT
OUT AREAS THAT COULD CREATE
THAT AND BEGIN AMBIGUITY OR
THAT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT WE HAVE PUT IT ON THE
FRONT END. INSTEAD OF BEING
FRUSTRATED ON THE BACKEND.
NINETY AND I APPRECIATE THAT IN
AND- YOU DID RIGHT GOOD ANSWER
ON ON SPECIFICALLY THE FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE BUT IS USING THAT IS
A BIT OF AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE I
THINK IT JUST SEEMS LIKE. THE
PREDECESSOR. I WANTED AN
OUTCOME. BUT WAS FRUSTRATING
ULTIMATELY TO WHAT THE PURPOSE
OF DISCLOSURE. AND
TRANSPARENCY. THAT WAS EMBODIED
IN IN IN THE BILL AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN FIGURE
OUT. WAYS TO OVERCOME THOSE.
THOSE DIFFERENCES I HAVE BEEN
CHASTISED BY JUDGES. WHO TELL
US THAT OUR JOB IS TO WRITE
CLEAR LAW YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN
TO THEM. THAT'S NOT REALLY OUR
JOB OUR JOB IS TO PASS THE LAW
THAT THE BEST WAY WE CAN. GIVEN
THE DYNAMICS THIRTY PEOPLE TO
SIT ON THE SCHOOL. AND WE ARE
NOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE AS CLEAR
AND WE ARE GOING TO NEGOTIATE
OVER SOME VERY SPECIFIC SO YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN. THAT THE
ULTIMATE THE INTERPRETATION WAR
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
COMPLETELY CLEAR AS WE
NEGOTIATE PRETTY HEAVILY SOME
OF THESE BILLS. CAN BE A
CHALLENGE BUT I HOPE THAT GIVEN
YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
PROCESSES AND WHAT WE DO. THAT
WE CAN HAVE SOME LINES OF
COMMUNICATION TO CLEAR THINGS
UP. SO THAT THERE'S NOT ALL TO
MILLION FRUSTRATION. AT THE END
ON THE ISSUE OF. PUBLIC TRUST
KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THINGS IN THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT. THAT IS IMPORTANT THAT.
AND WHEN THE QUESTIONS THAT
THAT I. **** I THINK THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT CONFLICT
THAT IS DEVELOPED OVER THE
YEARS. AND THAT IS WITH LOCAL
DJS AND EVEN WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. TAKING
CAMPAIGN MONEY AS IS.
TRADITIONAL FROM ORGANIZATIONS
IN AND FOR US BECAUSE OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE ROLE THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A DIRECT AS AS
DIRECTOR CONNECTION GOOD FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR FOR EVEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVING
SPECIFIC DISCIPLINARY
RESPONSIBILITY OVER A GROUP
THAT IS GIVING CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS I THINK THIS
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AND I JUST WANNA GET YOUR TAKE
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT DO YOU.
DISAGREE WITH THAT. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THAT THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT AND PRESSING
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
WHEN IT COMES TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES
BUILDING THAT TRUST BACK
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THE BILL-
THE CONCEPT THAT YOU REFER TO.
SPECIFICALLY THAT A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHO HAS CRIMINAL
CHARGING POWER THAT IS VERY
UNIQUE AMONG ELECTED OFFICIALS.
IF THEY RECEIVE A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION FROM A POLICE
UNION AND THEN ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR AN INVESTIGATION OF A
MEMBER OF THE POLICE UNION A
POLICE OFFICER- THEN THEY CAN-
EITHER NOT. WE CAN PROCEED WITH
THE INVESTIGATION IF THEY'RE
NOT TAKING- DIVERSITY CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION OR THEY WOULD BE
RECUSED IF THEY WERE- IF
ACCEPTING THAT CONTRIBUTION I
THINK THAT THAT WAS A PROPOSAL
THAT I- CAME FORWARD WITH. TO
HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
REBUILDING COMMUNITY TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY I'VE HAD. PEOPLE COME
UP TO ME AND SAY. HOW CAN THEY
BE A MAKE AN OBJECTIVE
DECISION. ON THIS ON THIS
POLICE OFFICER. ON WHETHER THEY
USED EXCESSIVE FORCE OR- YOU
KNOW- YOU KNOW VIOLATED EIGHTY
TO NINETY TWO. WHEN THAT WHEN
THAT UNION HAS GIVEN A
CONTRIBUTION TO THAT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND SO. THAT WAS A
CLEAR INDICATION TO ME THAT
THAT TRUST IS MISSING. AND MY
HOPE IS THAT THAT BILL WOULD
HELP RESTORE THAT TRUST. AND I
AGREE AND I KNOW YOU GOT WE GOT
SOME PUSH BACK. FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ON THAT SO I
AM GLAD. THAT YOU ARE PROPOSED
FOR THIS POSITION UNDERSTAND
THAT ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK IT
IS CLEAR IT DOES NOT MESS IN MY
VIEW DOES NOT MEAN THAT THERE'S
A CONFLICT. THAT POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS. AND ACTUAL CONFLICT
SOMETIMES THAT DRIVES OUTCOMES.
IS DETRIMENTAL TO BUILDING
TRUST CONFIDENCE KIND OF ACROSS
THE BOARD- AND THEN IN MY FINAL
COMMENT TO IT IN I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE THIS IS
BEEN RAISED A LITTLE BITON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE
CALIFORNIA THIS IS SOMETHING WE
STRUGGLED WITH. QUITE A BIT I
THINK THAT CALIFORNIA HAS LED
THE NATION FOR DECADES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT. I
THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S.
OFFICE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB ON
ENVIRONMENTAL FOR-
ENVIRONMENTAL. ENFORCEMENT OF
OUR LAWS HOWEVER THE PIECE THAT
IS REALLY THE TO ME THE NEXT
GENERATION STEP THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE IS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
BECAUSE IF WE JUST ENFORCE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THE WAY WE
HAVE WE KNOW THAT WE'RE LEAVING
COMMUNITIES BEHIND. AND YET IN
AGGREGATE CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
AIR CLEAN WATER ARE EXEMPLARY
BUT IF YOU DRILL DOWN AND LOOK
AT SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THAT IS
NOT THE CASE. SO WHAT I'M
HOPING IS THAT INSTEAD SHE
GIVEN YOUR EXPERTISE YOUR
BACKGROUND AND YOUR SENSITIVITY
TO SEE ISSUES. IS THAT. THAT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE WHAT HAS
BEEN EXEMPLARY ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT. AND RECAST IT AS
NECESSARY AS IS NECESSARY WITH
MORE OF AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE LANDS SO THAT THAT
BECOMES WHAT THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM THE PRIMARY DRIVER TO
BEHIND THE FORCING MECHANISM
BECAUSE I THINK TAT IS. A LONG
STANDING DEFICIT IN HOW WE HAVE
VIEWED ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ALL
THE TIME THOSE COMMUNITIES OF
LOS AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
LOSE SO I AM JUST ASKING THAT
YOU WHICH YOU HAVE SAID BUT
THIS IS I THINK A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. ISSUE THAT THAT WE
LOOK AT ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ESPECIALLY BERMAN FORTRESS-
DEPARTMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
THROUGH THAT EQUITY LENS
THROUGH THAT JUSTICE LET.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT LEADS US
TO DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS AND
POTENTIALLY DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES IF. 100% YEAH GOOD
AND I JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP INTHIS HOUSE- YOU
SOME OF OUR QUE HAN LAUGHTER
VERY SIMILAR QUESTION. WITH THE
SAME CONCERN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
WE HAVE REALLY PUT A STAKE IN
THE GROUND ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
NOT JUST DEFENDING PROTECTING
OUR ENVIRONMENT AS YOU
MENTIONED BY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE. AT THE INTERSECTION OF
POVERTY POLLUTION DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE SEEN AND
PRIORITIZED AND- AT THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BEST SET UP WHEN HE
WAS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL. I HAD
THE FORESIGHT AND VISION AND
VALUES TO CREATE THE BUREAU
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WHERE
THOSE VALUES THAT LANDS IS
EMPHASIZED AND PRIORITIZED. IN
HIS HOUSE AND I WANT TO BUILD
ON THE THAT HIS VISION AND HIS
VALUES AND CONTINUE THAT WORK
WITH THE EQUITY LINES THAT YOU.
MENTIONED WHICH WHICH I HAVE
EVERY CONFIDENCE IN WHICH IS
WHY IT WASN'T REALLY A
QUESTION. BUT I. AM JUST
EXCITED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES
AND THEN BECOME. PERVASIVE AND
WHAT THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL IN HOW THAT OFFICE
VIEWS ITS ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES- CROSS THE
BORDER IS THROUGH THAT. EQUITY
LEFT. YEAH YES OKAY THANK YOU
ALL WE'VE BEEN HERE A LONG TIME
WE MADE FOR MR BONTA STANDS FOR
MANY TIMES SO WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR IS A MOTION AT AND
THAT MOTION THE ME JUST BE
CLEAR ABOUT THE MOTION FOR A AT
THE END THE MOTION IS THAT THAT
THIS SPECIAL COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADVISE AND CONSENT TO THE
APPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR OF
ROB BONTA AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT IS THE MOTION I'M LOOKING
FOR SOME OF. WE ARE A CULTURE
I'M NOT PUTTING. OKAY SO FROM
OUR OPINION AND SECONDED FROM.
FROM THIS WEEK'S THAT IS THE
MOTION ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE TAKE
A VOTE MR BONTA AS I DO IN MY
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
YOU. THE LAST WORD. THE BILL
HERE A LONG TIME SO I'LL BE
BRIEF I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE DIALOGUE THANK YOU
FOR UPLOADING ALL OF YOUR-
PASSIONS AND PRIORITIES AS IT
AND SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS. IT
HI I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD HAVE THIS MOTION.
YEAH I HOPE. THAT I HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BEING CONFIRMED. BUT
I ALSO HOPE THIS THAT THERE
ARE. RELATIONSHIPS THE
COLLABORATION THAT WE'VE HAD.
HI I'VE BEEN A HUGE BENEFICIARY
OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE. I THINK
IF WE DO- THEN CALIFORNIA WILL
BE HUGE BENEFICIARIES OF OUR
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THAT AND
LEADERSHIP. I TO DO GOOD FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT. AFTER
PEOPLE WHO ARE HURTING SO. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION- I'M A DO MY BEST
TO MAKE MY FAMILY. ALL OF YOU
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PROP IF I'M CONFIRMED THANK YOU.
THNK YOU ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND THIS. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. OUR MOTION BY PARA
QUE HAN SECOND BY WICKS THAT
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADVISE AND CONSENT. TO THE
APPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR OF
ROB BONTA AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI. STONE NINE. STONE HI
OUR QUE HAN PARA QUE HAN HI
CHAD. CHAU HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM HI DALLY. DALLY NO
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI LACKEY.
LACKEY HI WICKS WICKS I IT.
MISTER CALDERON YOU HAVE AN
EIGHT HIGHS AND ONE NO THAT
MOTION PASSES THANK YOU ALL
VERY UCH WE'RE A GERMS.